[Music]
welcome everyone to the sports
gambling podcast presenting the football
tournament brought to you by mybookie.ag
and all things comedy i'm sean stackling
money green with my partner picks
ryan real money crammer what's happening
cream dog
what's up dude shout out to the kramer
gang
shout out to all the d gens that made a
shitload of cash on my picks earlier
this week
yes we have been uh we've been doing a
ton of uh madden sims and we're back
doing the football tournament over on
the all things comedy youtube channel
again if you're new it's pretty easy
we're gonna be simulating a madden game
between two madden teams we're not
playing it
we're not playing it to be key we're not
playing it no one is playing it the
computer is playing itself
we're gonna broadcast it as if it's a
real game
and just like a real game you can bet on
these games
all you got to do is go to mybookie.ag
promo code tft
deposit there get in on the action right
now they have a special uh
100 match on your deposit so you deposit
100 bucks you have 200
in your account to bet on simulated
video games and mlb season
kicking off they also have a free a 10
bet on
any mlb future that you want so you got
a team to win the world series et cetera
et cetera you can
uh get that for free third man in the
booth joining us as always
colby dan aka pick dundee aka the
dantabase
do you come to the land down under ooh
hello
hello how you doing guys we're doing
great i mean we're back here doing the
football tournament
and if you've been following along it's
uh it's been pretty sweet
if you filled out your little uh little
contest there picking who you think
would
make a run there uh we're giving away
ten thousand dollars in my bookie.g
credits that's up for grabs
i'm gonna send a link into the chat and
uh
yeah you can see where you're at in the
leaderboard we're gonna have a couple
games tonight
and so we have the divisional round
playoffs
the second the second night of the
divisional round second night of
division around we're basically running
back the same
2019 nfl playoffs that we just watched
and it's weird the simulated games have
been going the same as the real games
the only exception
is the ravens did beat the titans that's
the only difference from the 2019 nfl
playoffs
well and yeah the one seeds have already
advanced they're sitting waiting
to play tomorrow on championship
saturday where we'll play
the afc the nfc championship games and
then
the symbol the symbol which is zelda day
it's gonna be pretty awesome and much
like the super bowl where you're gonna
do a super bowl
aka symbol squares if you go to
sportsgamblingpodcast.com
squares you can sign up we will give you
a square much like at a super bowl party
where you have your square
and we're gonna give away five hundred
dollars cold hard cash so
sportsgamblingpodcast.com squares
you get that and uh yeah you're good to
go
mandarin tang checking in on the atc
youtube uh
chat hot pc versus pc action yes there
we go
seven uh seven decentest gaming saying
any madden impressions in the arsenal
well we got one right here
he's one of those guys who will get
penetration that's my guy
we got beau vice in the house beau vice
friend of the program
oh shout out to beau vice praising gator
fan he's he's in the chat over on twitch
all these five percent people all the
huge rip grooving
all right what are we doing for outfits
kramer i know colby likes to call him
out
can you make sure uh we have hopkins on
the texans so we're gonna need to update
the rosters
and uh good catch there in the chat
but yeah so we're using the 2020 roster
so deandre hopkins
is not on the houston texans he's on the
arizona cardinals as you know
a lot of ends a lot of outs lions let
outs and uh yeah there's a bunch of fun
player props including first touchdown
scored
that one's always great to get on uh and
kramer you have the honors right now the
of course i have the honors
i'm down one unit to you and right now
texans are getting eight and a half
points against the chiefs chiefs
uh eight and a half point favorites at
home texans plus 275 on the money line
what are you doing kramer you have the
option of uh of picking the bet here
uh well it seems hard to want to go
against
the chiefs right we've seen them in
these sims they're pretty damn good i i
don't know if i want to get involved in
the bill o'brien mobile
at this stage in my in my career um
i'm gonna take the chief should what am
i laying again
oh my god uh yes let's do it all right
i don't like rooting for a blowout but
this texas team they're scrappy oh stop
it
well we saw it we saw it recently on the
sims david johnson who
in the real world is just completely
done over the hill hey
he's looking good in the uh i know it's
weird to call a 27 year old stud
athlete over the hill considering i'm 36
and
uh no burst whatsoever but i think he's
over the hill
and uh yeah i've been doing a lot of
cardio lately
sean takes a flight and he gets like a
layover in houston and he's done for the
day
all right he's calling out david johnson
all right
i'm just gonna go with the white all
whites all right can't beat all white
powder white
again sportsgamblingpodcast.com squares
get those squares
so uh so i have the chiefs let's get
down to brass tacks sean sure
what are we betting on what are we
taking in the in the player props
we have all of these extra prop bets we
still have four minutes to get down
i'm going all red for the chiefs too all
right now
if you're if you've uh watched some of
these madden sims before the key is
as far as betting these player props you
got to find like the second third
receiver bet
over completions on those guys that's
usually fun i'm gonna start it out here
since i'm on the texans i'm gonna go
chalk deshawn watson passing touchdowns
over one and a half he gets it done he
did that last time we saw him
yeah are you worried that perhaps
lightning won't strike twice no i'll
back you on that oh here we go
that makes sense that's logical david
johnson rushing yards normally like to
go under there but it's a 57.5 that's
pretty reasonable
brandon cook's receptions five that
feels oh i mean
my lock of the century david fells over
five catch i'm with you there sean lock
that up there he's a guy
and now i sound like john groot here for
a second he's a here's a guy
we gotta get our going mentally
he's a guy that
they love uh getting at the ball to the
tight end so
and and maybe that's an angle you look
to play with these first touchdown props
which are
available over at my pookie.g make sure
you use that promo code tft
and uh yeah we'll get to those in a
second but fells
fouls is a good one i really like that
angle the the chief's props are just
crazy they're all so high
i'm gonna ride tyreek hill under seven
okay
and you know what i'm normally not gonna
do this
patrick mahomes passing touchdowns is
set an insane
three and a half give me the
underpassing
touchdowns i mean they can put up four
touchdowns but all of them being patrick
mahomes
i want to remind the audience especially
the kramer gang we we love to take those
unders
in the first and third quarter right
sean last we're doing two
they went on two the last game but five
oh and one before that one
what is what are the lines tonight sean
um uh the new site i gotta look a little
harder ten points for the first quarter
now very generous
very general first and third quarter
unders that's a lock
or you know as close as you can get in
the uh simulated madden game that you're
betting on
and make sure you subscribe to the
podcast while we're all here
we got a uh we just did our nfc training
camp preview did a
baseball preview podcast did an afc
training camp preview podcast
the real dub c209 saying garbage
i'm assuming he's talking about the
kansas city chiefs and their defense
because their defense has been
really soft over the uh over the
simulations and that and i think there's
gonna be some real
nice opportunities for the texans to put
up some points two minutes to post
get your bets in two minutes to post
sean
what else are you throwing out there
cause one that is a really interesting
to me
edward's rushing attempts over nine and
a half
do they do they just give it to edward's
uh is that edward solaire
yeah so and his touchdown over a half
touchdowns is plus 250. that's really
intriguing to me sean we should each
give out a first touchdown if we haven't
already oh yes
that was i was just let's close it over
there
damian williams also plus 200 for over a
half touchdown
it seems like there's a chance they're
gonna run one in uh
maybe i'm crazy sean who do you like for
the first touchdown
as i try to find him you know what this
is my guy with the catch prop i'm gonna
ride him in the first touchdown prop as
well big fan of the tight ends darren
fells plus 1200 a lot of value there
big dog give it to me colby
um give me a second here loading up
loading up trying to find this thing
i saw it a minute ago i have in front of
me colby we have the rough
i have the openers in front of me uh i
mean sean went fells for 12 to one i
like his onions i think you're going to
go with stills right that was your was
that your guy
uh no i'm just saying there's decent
value plus 1400 um
you know what you know what i'll take a
shot on stills plus 1400 stills at 1400
i'm i'm
you know what let's go not all the way
chalk but let's go
hardman me cole hardman
seven to one and i'm also i haven't
given you
my uh my other player prop i have not
given you a chiefs player prop
sean and to close it out it is 510 let's
get it started
but i'm going to take hardman over the
yardage hardman
over the yardage which is 62 and a half
general hobbies uh checking in on the
atc youtube chat wanting to know
what is happening here great question
fair question
what we're doing is we're going to
simulate a madden game we're going to do
the broadcast
as if we were watching a real game you
have a chance to bet on the game
even if you missed the the start of the
game here in a second my bookie.g promo
code tft they have live lines that you
can bet on player props
all right it's a lot of fun and madderin
uh tang sane
or manjun tang when comedy meets sports
is what
is happening and throw in a little
gambling aspect
and zooly i'll tell you what i like man
deshawn watson
plus 160 on throwing a pick
just one pick it's over a half yeah i
was gonna say i was gonna say shout out
to iverson over in the twitch chat cause
i'm gonna tail him on this one the
kramer gang is gonna follow you sir
plus 160 on watson over a half
uh interception shout out to colby too
the pick dundee crowd is on there
as well we're going all right are we
ready we're ready we're two past
two two minutes passed are you ready
sean i'm born right now you're getting
up for the blackjack table
you're ready to go i'm ready ready to go
all right let's do it
let it rip let's do it wait play ball
right baseball
i took the texans i'm with you with
green over here can i
can i share two can i share a funny
anecdote
i may have a local guy who helps me uh
facilitate some short-term
highly volatile investments on the
sports market
and the funniest thing ever is like you
know sports are back because he gave me
a call today
how's it going man just wanted to touch
sports are officially back but simulated
sports never went away let's get a
little cheers here
cheers
and again uh these uh simulated games
they feel a little bit more real
we have some wind going in the other
direction
if you're drunk and or high these sims
seem a little more real i'll throw that
out there
deshawn watson starting out of the
shotgun hold on i forgot to do something
uh oh backwards hack kramer coming out
sean watson back to throw checks it down
underneath
here we
we've not lost too many when the streams
all three cross together
i agree i completely agree
shout out to everyone who likes wearing
sunglasses inside
although the roof is open in kansas city
tonight sean the room beautiful
beautiful night here in the midwest yeah
we just got some barbecue in studio
watson back to throw looks to run and
down he goes right into the arms of
chris
oh no that's chandler no it's uh chris
jones
big time sorry yeah big time uh injury
here if that's real oh my goodness
injuries rarely happen in this game
of course the kramer fml tour creeping
up what'd you guys think of fauci's
opening pitch last night
did he fire it in there oh man you know
what you know what's bad when
50 cent and baba boo are trending after
you throw out of the opening pitch it
was not good
it was horrific someone tweeted out that
was the first time he's flattened a
curve
watson out of the shotgun third and
eight from his own 27 empty set
back to throw has time steps up in the
pocket he had him
he had fells too that would have been
nice so what do we have fels has won
fels has one he was open there deshaun
watson has
accuracy issues and you see that in the
regular nfl as well where
he makes these great spectacular
athletic plays but then he misses some
easy layups that he probably should have
had
all right great start now now i can
start rooting for that first touchdown i
love that we got the first touchdown
bets in the
wind at the back wait is wind blowing
both ways
it does it no they got a that kickoff
went out of the end zone
yeah but they seem like they uh yeah i
don't know what the hell is going on
with the wind
west changes you know it's a swirling
win we got
hurricane winds here yeah kansas city
got to say something nice about the
midwest they have great wind
great barb great kansas city barbecue
yeah mahomes out of the shotgun
bubble screen tyreek hill nothing there
jj what i'm in on the tackle i always
appreciated those waterfalls at the
kansas city royals uh
stadium when you know that when you hit
a home run you can see those waterfalls
yeah oh yeah that was awesome that was
uh in
in new york when when uh you would get a
mets home run and that giant apple would
come up
oh yeah or how about in milwaukee when
they used to pound that beer
oh and that guy would go down the slide
into the giant beer that's great
mahomes under center second and thirteen
pitch it out to damien williams
what a gross start for this kansas city
team shout out to deluxe picks over in
the twitch
jj watt making his uh name known here
as i mean i was that's the newest update
i feel like because
he is much better than he was
represented earlier in the other updates
who was what what has taken a step
forward
in the recent updates for sure i agree
with that
mahomes out of the shotgun third and 15
back to throw
completes it easy pitching
travis kelsey picks up 20 out to the 37.
and he was a guy i was considering
but i feel like we've been disappointed
by kelsey in
sims past so as i think
i think we're still burned kramer we
still have ptsd from the time we bet
on all all his player props put him in
fantasy in that playoff game against the
titans he gets knocked out in the first
half
we were cashing tickets oh we're just
cooked this is a douche
mahomes to kelsey again easy pitching
catch
down to the 38 into texas this might be
a long day for y'all
y'all y'all you ready for a live number
sean over at mybookie.ag use that promo
code tft and yes you can still bet on
the game
arguably more fun depend on it now than
before the game yes
live plus nine plus 300 on the money
line 53 and a half is the total
mahomes under center i formation handed
off to damian williams and there's jj
again pushing the pile back you don't
want to know what's going in at the
bottom of that pile
second and 11 from the 39. funny story
from wednesday or tuesday night on the
sims
sean took over jordan howard six and a
half rushing yards
jordan jordan howard finished with two
carries for negative seven yards
i took it too man that was mahomes out
of the shotgun second eleven
another handoff i knew they were going
to run the ball i knew that that was
and that's edward solaire first carry of
the game third and two from the third
so you're supposed to reinforce my my
sim prop
godness when it comes to this player
prop situation you liked edward solaire
over 10 carries he's already had one
nine and a half carries he's only had
one and they seem to be giving
uh damian williams a decent i'm just
gonna track that one for fun i didn't
actually bet it but
third and two my home's under center
lonely come on get in there get in there
hands it off to damian williams breaks
the tackle to the outside 30 2010
touchdown we called it kansas city
chiefs we called out that rushing
touchdown prop what was his
first touchdown prop damn it you already
supposed to take the run
12-1 really
[Applause]
shout out to everyone on the damian
williams for if you got
if you got damien williams first
touchdown smash some emojis over in the
twitch chat
and if you're a fantasy football guy i
think damien williams is criminally
underrated right now
everyone is drafting edward solaire
really high
and certainly the chiefs use the first
round pick on him super athletic fun
exciting player
but they're going to have like 10
practices before the season
starts
and damien williams was really good i
mean he was right on the edge of
becoming super bowl mvp
he was a big part of that late success
in the playoffs
i appreciate how for damian williams you
just did the ace ventura where he was
quoting uh roy finkel it's like what
would you know about ray fink was like
soccer style kicker four-year grad call
your high that was you right there with
damian williams
damien williams he's just getting
disrespected
well voice were you on that 12-1 please
tell me you were on that 12-1 shout out
to mr bear over in the atc
youtube chat calling it unrealistic
that's my
that's my favorite yeah you're right
it's a video game hey
you know they're the sims are doing the
best they
can houston out to a uh
seven point deficit and yes there are uh
seven
decens gaming there are cpu challenges
there are yeah now guys are we still
allowed to say
chiefs uh aren't they covering for the
chiefs the indians are currently in
conversations
well they've renamed themselves the
cleveland baseball team
that that is where we're gonna get to
where it's just we've gotten rid of all
nicknames
i'll be honest that was that was a great
you by dan watts
out of the shotgun oh completes it to
fuller now if
if dan center was a smart sarcastic guy
and he's just like all right you want me
to rename it how about i just rename it
the washington football team there you
happy
it's probably it probably wasn't that it
was probably more just like
uh i can't think of anything better than
redskins right now i'm just gonna punt
it to next season i don't know though
because he grew up a die-hard
fan his dad was a diehard fan so
i think he might be
it had a little of that you in
there you know what i mean watson ahead
of the pistol
bubble screen to fuller gets the first
down down he goes
it's a nice form tackle right there
seven gaming in the youtube atc saying
the kansas city seawords
i like that that's that's fun everyone
thinks you're calling them but
really it's just
can't drop any chief bombs on this uh on
this stream
[Applause]
under center hands it off to david
johnson nothing there loses three
where was this the other night sean
man chad's getting funny is it
i can't uh tin somo won saying they will
rename themselves to the kfc chickens i
could see some product placement getting
involved
i could see andy reid being behind that
yeah he would be just sitting on the
sideline with a bucket right there
he's like why don't we call the chicken
cutlets
watson scrambles picks up eight extra
thin
extra thin with the cutlets please
remember when kansas city or the
you pounded them out right remember when
kfc came out with a double deckers where
it was like instead of pieces of bread
it was just fried chicken patties and
you're thinking yourself what kind of
human being would eat one of these
right here andy reid you saw the mcgang
bang was trending a couple weeks ago
third and five nice pitching catch to
the outside
and that's kenny stills who had that
three and a half that was intriguing
very low
i thought about it didn't do it now
they're near midfield texans offense
kind of getting a little uh
get a little heat going getting going
watson out of the shotgun first and ten
midfield
[Applause]
back to throw surveys the field has time
checks it down there we go
chief's passing defense has some holes
will fuller out of notre dame you see
notre dame playing in the acc this year
creamer
i like it finally finally they're making
it official yeah
it's like they had that girl that
girlfriend for so long that they didn't
officially call their girlfriend like
man ty teo did
that's a what a great story god bless
manti teo for thinking that no one would
ever research it
watson looks to run picks up a handful
there
making it second and three watson uh
rushing props looking
off to a good start there nicholas
mayfield on the youtube atc
is this just drinking betting fun just
started the entertainment
lol thank you sir nose beers drinking
betting it's all fun
mg's and remember the symbol tomorrow
we got three games afc championship nfc
championship and the symbol
back to back to back starting at three
o'clock pacific
then five o'clock pacific then the
symbol kicking off around
7 p.m pacific and we're doing super bowl
squares for the symbol
just go to sportsgamelandpodcast.com
squares giving away five hundred dollars
cash
very easy to sign up sports
gamingpodcast.com squares
third and three and they hand it off god
damn it
and sean i don't think you mentioned it
but we will be having a
proper bra toast in the pre-game show
shout out to the brat stop at kenosha
wisconsin the official
broad sponsor the sports gambling
podcast if you're in the greater north
american
area make sure you check out the broad
stop
hashtag more than just brought through
here in mexico city
great quick flight to field goals up and
it's good that's a great part about
naftas
our neighbors of the north and the south
have been able to enjoy
the veal sausage they have all different
types of brats the cheese
the bronze stop hooked us up with a care
package and my wife loves the chocolate
cheese oh
i know you ever heard of chocolate
cheese never heard of it it's delicious
all right sean will the leaderboard for
the wins contest be updated before
tomorrow i will i believe in you kramer
i will update it after each game tonight
how about that there we go how about
that
that's pretty awesome and again first
quarter under is pushing right now
by the way no thank god they moved it to
ten yeah normally it's nine and a half
or nine
and we would have been cooked so you
were saying sean
what was i saying squarespool
any coleslaw sandwiches tomorrow no i'm
all meat baby
yeah we're gonna the production crew is
gonna be grilling us brats
like the stars we are
[Laughter]
you know you've made it when you have
people making you brats well when you
have brass beings
flown in on dry ice yes we got bronze
mailed to us for
a simulated sports broadcast it does
this is when you know you've arrived in
show business
when people are mailing your brats and
you're calling play-by-play for
simulated madden
games we're living the dream first and
ten from their own 35 the chiefs take
over up
four here at home remind me to tell my
dad that the next time he calls him
calls me a loser i've made it dad
another handoff here to edward
solaire second carry of the game
yeah bum second and seven something the
kids say now my kids walk around calling
each other's bums but they do it they do
so in like 30s
gangster accents i got to be honest tom
green
for me whenever i think of bum i do
think of tom green that bum dumb
awesome shout out to tom green what's
what's he up to nowadays mahomes back to
throw out of the shotgun bullet pass to
edwards hillary getting him involved in
the
passing game bathing in his fortunes
i don't know if he made that much money
he's do he's doing stand-up on the road
so you know he's not
he's not set for life if he's headlining
the saint louis funny bone
not that that wouldn't be an awesome gig
better say i'll take that right now dude
are you kidding me
but if you're tom green going from like
starring and freddie got fingered
again big sausage fan first and ten
muhammad's out of the shotgun empty set
from his own 47. oh what the
airmail is that wasn't he married to
drew barrymore didn't he get half
he did uh i don't know she's got a lot
of money right
drew barrymore she was an et bro drew
barrymore was uh she's not
if she's marrying tom green someone's
getting in her ear about a prenup
you don't come from hollywood money and
marry tom green without a prenup how did
that even happen
i don't even understand the shotgun
second and ten from the 46. that's like
ted danson whoopi goldberg ted danson
was number one
in the country defaulted the sideline up
for
kelsey that's a hot take you think you
think ted danson was the catch in that
relationship dude i'm just saying he was
the highest paid actor on tv you know i
mean you got to go after dancing there
i like the boldness of not having
eyebrows drew barrymore had a great line
someone was asking her like how to get
involved in you know acting and becoming
a star
she was like just fake it till you make
it it's like you're an e.t at age
six like what were you what were you
faking your dad was a movie star
mahomes out of the shotgun third and ten
completes it to me
cole hardman that's my guy inside the 40
at the 39 they're on the move what about
when she was like doing blow at like 12
years old
yeah you know she's seen some but i
mean to get through and cut you know
that is true
tony junior dude that guy i have a
friend
shout out to richard alderweire he's on
our own look at you name dropping
he has a great story of uh them giving
downy junior assets
birthday party hands it off
damian williams with the carry uh joseph
dietzmann dychemon tom green is a
podcast pioneer yeah he was
early on from like getting his own thing
started i actually uh
i worked on his early video show for a
while there
holmes out of the shotgun second and
eight from the 37.
[Applause]
damian williams again with the carry not
much there let's go baby
sean shout out to h-town over on twitch
all kidding aside these guys are more
entertaining than the
monday night football crew espn has wow
thank you did they announce their new
crew uh it boogers back
i think booger's back booger's fine
shout out to garrett can we pause the
game need to go do a quick
mid-game jerk i'm excited too bro
wow now i thought i was the fan of uh
the texans defense
come on dude big incomplete they're
forcing fourth and 10.
they have the win that they're back will
they try a 56-yard field no no
we want no points here we want to walk
away with a push a punt
all but locks that up yeah they will go
for it though right
oh and they're they're doing it this
kicker has a month 56 yarder from the
left hash
monster leg all right he can miss this
he can miss this it's up
oh he missed it good day
[Applause]
not a good start not a good start that's
all right though that's a long game bet
you bet that every time
[Applause]
it's like betting every first half under
in march matt in the first round
of uh the in the ncaa tournament i i
used to r.i.p
i used to be horrible at watching
judging if the kicks were going to go in
i was right i was right there you are
you're getting something you have the
middle seat so you have the better angle
see i have the i have like the big
cement beam in my way over here
mr bear and sean's just blind as a bat
you know i i do need uh glasses
but my vanity won't allow me to wear
them on on cam
i wear them at home when my wife yells
at me like you're squinting
can you give me a lemonade hun bakery
you're mistaken with banker mayfield
that dude
walked across the goddamn stadium for
lemonade and she had the nerve to ask
for a
that is uh that is marriage in a
nutshell mr bear checking in on the atc
youtube
you guys are pretty entertaining should
have given this a shot sooner
hey man there's still time we got
another late game and then
the trifecta the three o'clock five
o'clock seven o'clock
afc nfc championship in the symbol make
sure you grab one of those
symbols square sportsgamingpodcast.com
squares
are we out yet for 500 cold hard cash up
for grabs
david johnson with the carry getting
going
there's my boy uh to know
somo one saying i was definitely
expecting everyone to be drunk by now
wait till uh the symbol i have a feeling
we're gonna be pretty liquored up
there is a point where we start slurring
our words and uh and i start yelling at
colby about john elway where the show
becomes not entertaining anymore
watson with the sack the great people
get sacked
the great people of moscow idaho had to
deal with that for for about
four hours that was an experience
we were staying at this bed and
breakfast out of town like it was like a
ranch
something it was like an airbnb like
farmhouse and so
there wasn't like a separate house we
were just staying in someone's like
third room
and we're like this argument started
hours ago at the bar
at a pool it's still happening we get
back
the argument continues as we walk in the
house
we're still talking about john elway
versus tom brady i think they can rate
the customers too so they're probably
like really great
these people were arguing oh that'd be
funny if somehow it was included in our
airbnb rating like
these guys are the one guy
thought john elway is the greatest
quarterback of
all time watson back to throw
third and four completes it to fuller
and fuller seems to be his go-to guy
here fuller's on the way up dean hogue
saying uh the problem was you were in
moscow
the vandals go broncos well sean
wanted to go to russia and we just had
to say hey we'll take you to
take you to the closest thing i enjoyed
moscow first off communism
and you're and you're we're talking
about moscow i know we went up to
washington state
hang out with our boy mike leach coach
mike gleach
invited us up there to hang out catch a
game at washington state
on the campus we couldn't find anywhere
in pullman watching
parents weekend it was pretty last
minute fuller over three and a half
catches
cashes shout out to alejandro
nice where are you guys uh
at in the world where's your location
you know i'm feeling good
watson ahead of the shotgun second and
thirteen looks to run now
call fails bells with the olay
he gets a block there watson is gone
honey badger just did cam newton just he
just pulled the superman
dwight howard who uh do you see the news
dwight howard is a q
anon guy i don't click on dwight howard
news but on youtube
apparently live number over at
mybookie.ag
watson out of the shotgun third and 15.
completes it short of the sticks
madden would hate that on third down you
got to throw past the sticks
that if you have kenny stills over prop
you're happy there but everyone else is
an odd
texans plus 11 and a half plus 400 shawn
on the money line 51 is now
the total chad roth checking in indiana
on the atc youtube maybe he's a big
colts fan
shout out i got a sweet spot for colts
got some california guys fellow
california dudes check it in
of course i'm originally from bethlehem
pennsylvania do we have anyone from
the the great state of north dakota in
the house
oh man that's a bit of an ass and do
they have energy
now the chiefs will take over up seven
at home from their own 20. they win this
game they move on to the afc
championship of the football tournament
and totally cool by me if you want to
throw out my wins in the twitch chat
just to remind me
mahomes out of the shotgun plenty of
time
gets into the outside again kelsey how
did he break that tackle come on now
he's uh is that kelsey's third catch
this is going to be a long game
3 57. he can't slow him down at all
nicholas mayfield
from brunswick georgia oh oh shout out
go dogs we got some minnesota in the
house
michigan there we go brunswick is that
where they
invented bowling sounds like it thumbs
out of the shack and empty set first and
ten
get in there lot deeper on the outside
let's go oh man conley with the pick
texans take over at their own 43. did
anyone take the over on the
interceptions from a home i took it for
watson yeah i took it for watson
huge fuller
he is just racking up catches i i got a
little oh no of course
oh no whoever said this game isn't
realistic will fuller just got
injured that is the most realistic thing
that can happen and my
under patrick mahomes three and a half
passing touchdowns looking good
looking great right now because they've
had one touchdown
and it wasn't a uh it was a running time
holmes
okay interceptions it was minus 125. so
he's loose with the ball they expected
that
interesting juvenile grandpa on our
twitch page saying middle of cornfield
illinois
shout out to illinois love illinois go
uh illinois state
you know ooh mitchell wooten saying uh
saying he's from denver oh shout out to
denver
i love denver yeah i lived in uh denver
as a kid
and uh colorado's an awesome state he's
also michael's also uh supporting you
believing that uh believing that elway
is
greatest quarterback of all time well
he's from the area i get it
you know evan lagna in the 18th
youtube's saying damn bethlehem pa not
that far from there
well i'm sure some people from the
northeast here some some jersey rats
some diehards watson with the play
action first and ten from the 23.
oh you gotta catch that is that the
backup
a fellow jersey legend just like joey
theismann
name them just anyone anyone i'm up
there with them
we got a uh arlene 2206 in las cruces
new mexico
hell yeah the i mean how many how many
how many
state championship rings joe theismann
got you know does he have any i don't
know got a super bowl ring
oh oh incomplete that was that's
one thing with these latest updates the
tip pass is super realistic
trying to get it to the uh that's not
fels that's the other tight end
oh jordan thomas getting involved for
some reason we got some philly trash
over in the atc
heavy sex go birds baby
watson under the shotgun huge third down
here third and ten from the 23 11
minutes left to go in the second
back to throw plenty of time steps into
the throw wide open checks it down to
fells i think so
second or third third take the second
catch of the game
still need three more i mean get a
little more aggressive with that route
you had plenty of time you got to throw
it 10 yards
[Applause]
pittsburgh some yin's in the house oh we
got lancaster pennsylvania oh
shout out to the amish yes
maybe uh maybe there's some maybe
there's some weird loophole that the
amish are allowed to watch
simulated madden games if you're doing
that use electricity and take a picture
i'm sure i'm sure i'm sure that's the
first time steve has ever
ever been in the chat room mentioned
lancaster and gotten the amish joke
mickey robo says port washington
wisconsin home of the show step by step
oh
whoa wow shout out to you sir
houston cuts it to a four point deficit
uh
chiefs up 10-6 here 10-18 left to go in
the second
shout out to h-town over in twitch uh
blaming the devils
during the heyday of my childhood
winning championships with marty brodeur
uh like most people feels like they
ruined hockey for a bit with the uh
before checking that's your opinion bro
are they are we still allowed to say
devils
well the jersey devil is a fictitious
demon that you're taught to be scared of
i always thought it was white devil oh
so well there is a lot of white trash in
south jersey
how dare you crammer i mean there is
it's i mean i'm from there i can say
that
i told you i was talking to someone who
has a girlfriend from new jersey and
she he was asking me like when she's
gonna adjust and i was like well it took
me seven years to realize that
everything they say about new jersey is
true
steve wolf saying uh amish blow dog
quarters that's a great expression he
get you get stuck behind a buggy for 10
miles before work
holds out of the shotgun play action has
plenty of time ball
interception all the way down the field
[Applause]
come on man almost caught almost
intercepted
total hand job the amish perfect use of
the word handrail
we got atlanta up in the place to be san
antonio
although i gotta say if you're a teen
like a 17 16 year old kid growing up in
lancaster
you catch one of those girls on a rum
springer making up for lost time that
may
that may be an ideal scenario i've heard
it's like catching a wave during a
hurricane
[Laughter]
watson or sorry uh mahomes back to throw
gets it to sammy watkins i think that's
his first kitchen he can't fumble you
just need to get in the way be in the
right place at the right time and close
your eyes and pray
[Applause]
hold on for dear life oh man it sounds
fun there's a joke about getting blown
in there
i'm not gonna go there it's a young
man's game val kilmer lived in boise
says
dean hogue shout out to uh doc holliday
wait
hold on h town is alleging that marty
brodeur was banging his wife's sister
too
mahomes deep ball out of the play action
there we go make the catch boy
incomplete
dude he had him beat come on ty well
again that's
uh that chat users uh
was banging his wife's sister and
winning cups
wow we got to get we got to get a link
on that h-town you didn't know this
i never heard that no is that common
weren't you guys with me where was i in
the world where someone was
showing me photos mahomes hands it off
wow and that's edward solaire and he
loses yards third and 13.
neither team doing a damn thing on the
ground no it's uh
it's weird both offenses kind of cold
which is crazy if you remember watching
this playoff game
it was just a shitload of scoring
texans jumped out to a crazy lead and
then mahomes and the chiefs came all the
way back
mahomes out of the shotgun third and 13.
back to throw oh holmes is just
six man he is just off it is not
so tied by a lot of time left sean a lot
of time and of course that's the
bill bird drop bill's been a guest
friend of the program had him on the
podcast
obviously huge fans showtime by holmes
[Music]
legend fourth and 13.
and i'm thinking i'm thinking i might be
advising the kramer gang to
buy because the line is now starting to
creep down it's back to chiefs minus
seven and a half
texans is plus 250 on the money line
you know and i'm gonna say it i if we
flip to the other side of seven
the chiefs is a buy because we're gonna
see a second half explosion
like you've never seen before
[Applause]
watson under center first and 10 from
their own 13.
[Applause]
hand it off to david johnson breaks a
couple tackles
you know i'm going to advise get a
little sprinkle on that texans money
line
they're in this game right now that's uh
that's too high for this texans team
which has been scrappy in these bad
sims did you see the news today sean
what's that
premier league announced the season's
gonna start september 12th so we only
have to wait
a month in a couple weeks thank god for
soccer english soccer starts
oh you're not into it anymore watson out
of the pistol second and seven from the
16th
another handoff to david johnson not
much there
and of course if you're betting on these
games go to mybookie.edu use that promo
code tft
a 100 deposit bonus
100 so you can turn 100 into 200
just by using that promo code tft
come on now yeah i mean everything was
indicating a big score in this game
watson kicks it down underneath to duke
johnson out of the backfield
there we go that's the first down and
then some out to the 32
texans on the move this has been a slow
first half right it has like it's it's
we're already well into this game it's
still seven minutes left
like a lot of possessions for both teams
a lot of puns
andy reid really was just done well in
this game
watson under center 100 pounds wider
from his own 32 play action
was that to his left there we go gets
rid of it he just took a shot
he did that's classic classic
desean watson trying to make a play
taking a hit that he might not have
needed to take
yeah i mean i i think everything is
indicating to me that we're going to be
loading up on the over in the second
half if not
sooner yeah cause things kind of have a
way of evening them out in these uh
16 points is way under schedule right
now watson under center hands it off to
johnson not much there one yard and it
might be time to strike after this
possession
after the punt oh what's happening
well you said strike and i just got the
uh
[Music]
oh man h-town just dropped that article
oh wow that dude that's a great story
pretty hilarious
shout out to marty burner i didn't know
he was a goat off the field too watson
out of the shotgun checks it down to
duke johnson
wow huge break these linemen have
hands like babies is that is that
laramie
might be he knows how to yeah he knows
how to
handle a thing
don't know where i was going with that
no it's fulton uh okay
all right obviously laramie tunzel was
the guy who
uh his draft stock fell and there's a
video of him
smoking a gas mask how uptight
well the craziest part about that video
is
he's doing a gas mask bong and in the
background there's a confederate
flag as a black dude i mean
he went to ole miss yeah i got that
you're right that was the helmet
that's probably this yeah the team's
logo
that's why we're hit we're mississippi
state fans here it's the pro mississippi
state podcast
mike leach my bookie has a line oh no
watkins with the completion picks up
eight
to betty does my bookie really have a
line on whether or not lebron will get
coven
yes minus 250 no that locked that up
there's no way that dude's getting
covered they haven't had they haven't
had one positive test yet in the bubble
shout out to hildarius because of the
philly well i don't know what he's
talking about but he said phillies suck
and nola
sucks so oh no do they have odds on
lebron catering to china again
hand it off to edward solaire picks up
three yards that's enough for
a first down for the kansas city chiefs
deluxe picks
alerted me to a 47 and a half it's gone
it's 48 now
i'm so tempted to buy i'm so tempted to
buy that over
well nola is uh losing
marlins are up 3-1 on the philly's top
of the six i'm gonna wait till i think
we'll get value at halftime right now
still
come on jj where's the fumble edward
zeller with his fifth carry of the game
picks up two second and eight clock
continues to run chiefs have three
timeouts plenty of time left here
i mean what's the second half over going
to be 25
big like 25 and a half maybe so they can
only make it so high
41. yeah so basically are we expecting
there to be we've only seen one
touchdown so far in the first half
mahomes out of the shotgun
back to throw slides to his right
interception
eight for 16 for mahomes what is going
on
and he's just missed oh there's there's
there's mascara homes
i don't know what they did but he looks
like a goth teen with just like
his eyes are sunken in and it looks like
he's got mascara on
show tied my homes mahomes out of the
shotgun third and eight from his own 33.
back to throw
has time completes it into texas
territory you got to make him pay on
that last ball
you're you're in kansas city has a big
dog
you can't drop an interception like that
especially one you can easily take the
touchdown that could be the game
that certainly when we look back on our
bets that could be a game changer
mahomes under center i formation
gets it to damien williams wow shout out
to mark wade
as much as i missed baseball there's no
commentary on tv like you degenerate so
i'm watching this instead
of choosing us well
how about the blue jays they're gonna
get up they get to spend their time in
good old baltimore for what i understand
a buffalo is no
did they agree with it i thought so yeah
because i saw that they were looking at
at uh baltimore oh i thought it was
gonna be the uh
originally it was gonna be buffalo but i
think something happened there all right
a serious question sean is it is it time
to strike on 47 and a half
because if they score a touchdown i've
lost value mahomes out of the shotgun if
you can get a 46 and a half i'd do it 40
oh it is buffalo okay
it is buffalo new edwards hillary picks
up a couple third and three and
blue jays will be playing in buffalo
this year that's fun that's a win
i was gonna make fun of them getting
baltimore my strategist aka
beau vice is informing me i should take
the 47 and a half
let's go kramer gang over
[Applause]
we got to recover from this bro and now
is when you bet the uh over
wow look that that cookie cutter
it's not going to work
watson checks it down the stills breaks
the tackle
not much there clock continues to run
houston has three timeouts
how bad does patrick mahomes look he
looks horrific
maybe he had that contest with josh
allen and he lost it
shattered his confidence yeah of course
what you're referring to is the fact
that josh allen rated a 99 in arm
strength in the new madden
mahomes only 97 challenged josh allen to
a throw-off
watson out of the shotgun second to five
bullet pass to cooks
plenty of room down the side oh no
what what was the first half number sean
now the line's down to seven it was
cheap
probably like four chiefs favor by four
i bet it was i bet it's right on the
number
look at kenny stills with the downfield
blocking
watson out of the shotgun from the 33
one minute
left to go three timeouts
johnson motions up top list
we need a touchdown here
checks it down there he is fells no i
think that's the uh
damn it that's the other tight end
jordan aitkins
first and ten at the 55 they burned
their first timeout
let's get it going abby sex and marlins
are winning 4-1 now against the phillies
god damn it
yeah shout out to the baseball fans out
there we got we got some free baseball
picks coming up every day
shout out to our guy will mormon and uh
and and chris
under center checks it down to fells
there you go
first for a first down yeah if you guys
are interested in playing baseball we
got a baseball guy
gives out free mlb picks every day
i'm gonna send the uh link into the chat
but yeah every day
picks all the games against the spread
2-0
yesterday looking to make a run here
was that akins again no that was fails
okay that was from uh
that was a play before he said he didn't
get that first that's it second
initiative that's fine
watson back to throw has time steps into
it there we go
for a touchdown all we need is one more
johnson jr baby boom
shout out to magic man blanco over in
twitch sean picking fantasy baseball was
fantastic you know
our specialty is the nfl but for the
baseball episode we brought on some of
our
sgpn experts that's the point right we
bring an expert to lead
the idiots through the through the
forest yeah there's a couple sports we
really know
and there's some we don't but we got you
covered for everything now formula one
you want to talk
you want to talk some some race cars i'm
i'm all in
we have a nascar actually i will be in
jerry glanville i will be tweeting my
formula one picks
not this weekend but for next weekend
even though i'm going off the grid i'm
still betting on it
i love it hashtag
and reminder tomorrow uh not only will
we doing a broad
toast in the pregame show up into the
symbol uh we will be
also doing some decaf nose beers oh nice
aka
smelling salt so if you guys want to see
grown men do smelling salts
to get hyped up for a simulated uh
madden tournament tune in tomorrow
nights
and if you're tuning in what are you
doing not having a super bowl square
kramer i'm looking at these uh the list
here we're almost completely full are we
how many how many more squares do we
have we
it's a handful we're really down to the
wire here
so make sure you get yours in so you
have a chance at 500
sportsgamblingpodcast.com
they could throw another picture they
could i mean
he really should have had that one for
pick six doesn't matter or boy desean
watson it's even better because now
we're looking better for the passing
touchdowns for uh
desean watson and patrick mahomes zero
passing touchdowns in the first half
i'm feeling great on my under three and
a half and my texans plus 250 money line
anyone want to chase with me oh another
dangerous throw there to edward zelaire
who wants to chase with with uncle ryan
that's four now
uh let's do two units kansas city minus
four
two units kansas city minus four
i i mean you guys are going to be
feeling foolish when mahomes finally
activates
because he's been dog
i think they get they're going to get
points before the half this is going to
be a great steal
great steal mahomes out of the shack on
second and 13.
he wants to throw another one tyree
killed the catch but that was another
dangerous one
they used the timeout there third and
one i almost would have preferred the
hurry up there
and save the timeout because if you
don't get it here you're going to be
forced to punt
and texans have one timeout
come on dee where you at what mahomes
out of the shotgun third and one 36 like
seconds left to go in the half checks it
down underneath
not gonna do it
nicole hardman with the first down but
clock continues to run
give us a replay there you go tick that
drain that clock and now oh no they use
the timeout
they use the timeout very like andy reid
to blow this opportunity
this up
first and ten from their own 39.
mandarin tang saying 20 seconds can be
three plays
not in madden in in real life yeah but
madden is still hasn't figured out the
uh clock management they need to get out
of the hurry up
mahomes out of the shotgun first and ten
or it's one play
going back in coverage chelsea and that
could do it and that may do it for the
first time that should that's it
he's got to get his dancing oh this guy
eight yep seven six damn it can they get
a hail mary off before the half
no doesn't look like that's gonna happen
idiots that'll do it for the
first half houston wins the first half
so if you had texans money live
that's gotta pay nice right oh that's
gonna be two and three and a half three
to one
chiefs will start with the uh the ball
in the second half we're going to take a
quick halftime break here
show you guys uh the stats so you can
check in on your player props
i mean how do there i'm not even going
to complain right now the fact that he
has two turnovers is ridiculous dude
he's lucky he doesn't have like four
i know he looks like dog who's on
the sticks
who is on the sticks who's on the st all
right let's look at the prop market let
me pull up the props colby we can you
can help me
one touchdown away with watson yeah i
was gonna say i mean
watson having a pretty good game uh he's
well on his his completions was only 23
and a half he's already at 18.
attempts only 31. it seems like he's
going to get there
247 and a half was the yardage yeah
yeah he's looking good man and mahomes
still hasn't thrown a touchdown he's got
two picks
i know we if you're sean sitting on
under three and a half passing
touchdowns
that's gotta feel good can you grab me
one of those premium lights
yeah what'd shawn just do i don't know
sean he's dropping nose beers over here
yeah he's
he's getting silly all right what else
we got the let's head over to the
the rushing yards i mean well most of
that came on one carry
i feel like william's got what like 30
on that one touchdown right
yeah but just carries wise i think both
of them had low care i mean
i think edward zelaire was nine and a
half williams was maybe
a little bit more than that 10. so both
of them are on pace
your own pace to hit that i know i don't
want to hit it though now i need
homes to start going off no yeah we're
telling there are 10 rushes though
i know watson uh watson rushing yards
was 73 and a half so that we got some
work to do there
uh let's check out the receiving what
did i do i took fells
and i took let me go back to this
uh stills which lost watson over to okay
thanks bro
uh everything all right sean yeah i
spilled a lot of beer in your garage
apologies you mean the studio
yes look at this thing though is it
frozen
no no no i just slipped out of my hands
all right
so fellas what what is his catch it's
five right
yeah it's five uh he's at he's at three
we're doing all right kelsey
you know most will fuller is really the
only guy standing out as a guy who took
care of business in the first
um and he's hurt now watkins is he hurt
yeah how do we know if he's hurt no he
got injured i think he came back
back i think he came back did he i don't
remember him doing anything after
shout out to tomcat it says nice hat
colby shout out to
to wow love pullman peace and love
um so what else what do we got a
halftime line yet
we will we will just gonna cruise
through these stats over here
all right let's head over to mybookie.ag
sean
we use that promo code tft 100 deposit
bonus
and if you're looking in looking to get
in on baseball action
ten dollar free bet completely free with
uh a completely free free bet that's how
it works
[Music]
on any uh any mlb future you want
then you got the phillies right not a
good start for you no
not a good start for them to win the
world series maybe i'll double up after
this loss
this is where you say small sample size
limited sample size
only one out of 60 games the the major
league baseball
they're just so horrible with the way
they market the game they have this idea
to put
what 16 teams into the playoffs it's a
great idea which is a great idea
why did they announce it the day of like
announce it earlier so people can get
more interested in the season
it affects future bets like what are
they doing it feels like the kind of
thing you could
uh spend some marketing dollars around
hey we figured out a tournament
you're not tagged college football
speaking of college football subscribe
to the college experience we're
previewing all 130 division one college
football teams
oh you are you're amazing and kramer on
our uh mlb preview podcast
we were saying especially these first
couple games load up on the over how's
that going
tigers red 7-1 blue jays raised 6-3
there's still innings left in that
marlins phillies that's 5-1 bottom of
the six
red sox up seven nothing on the orioles
so i
i think there's some uh i think we're
gonna be looking pretty good with our
all overs
i don't know how to see the injury
report medical center
i don't know no i can't get to it cause
i just i don't know when you're doing
these simulations
it's really hard to pause so that is
a lot of his layouts 150 yards only
completing 60 percent
dude his quarterback rating was like
43.9 that's horrific
skeletor what time we started let me
know
yeah i mean at this point sean
i'm not loving my position i do like the
second
two units i i bet on the kansas city
minus four
uh i'm feeling good about my texans plus
250 money line do we have the second
half number is that
i'm trying to get it to load
my cpu is enrolling that processor a
learning computer
they're upgrading their neural net
processor as we speak
colby's already upgraded he's at my
house with my family eating my birthday
cake
which one is the what uh the birthday
cake line what is that
i think that's uh kindergarten cop yeah
i think that's kindergarten cup maybe
all right second half
second half number over at mybookie.ag
chiefs minus six and a half
26 and a half is the total sean
so which tells me with a
we have 23 points i bought 47 and a half
i have some value here i have two points
of value
how about that sean i'm sitting pretty
the team totals texans
10 and a half will the texans score more
or less than 10 and a half points in the
second half
chiefs is 16. chiefs get the ball too
right i say go over
26 and a half all right second half i
think that's a decent play i'm already
on the over 47.
let's double dip in a different way
let's go a unit on the chiefs
over 16. over 16.
of course in the twitch uh chat the guys
who gave us this drop
in smoke about weed we see you bo we see
you
yeah but bo stan please for an applause
mandarin tang with the great arnold
quote
who is your daddy and what does he do
that's
they always use that on the stern uh
crank calls and it was just so good
what do you mean who am i who's my daddy
i ain't telling you until you tell
me my name
who is your daddy and what does he do
why should i tell you what my dad does
that's kindergarten cop too man that
that movie is instagram
great lines that's a great well and
isn't that don't they have that
the one line about like uh the two the
girls are like
um our mom says our dad is a real
sexy yeah
abby sexton the birthday cake line is
from uh the sixth day
oh okay he might be right that's the one
where like the devil tries to kill
everyone right
no that's end of day no that's a
different one
dude after the game then i enjoy a nice
classic arnold schwarzenegger movie
i mean too much too much what's everyone
sitting on
let's let's see some bets that people
got what are you taking for the second
half
all right real quick while we're uh what
are you well we were talking about
arnold i have to put the
kramer can you play uh videos i forget
kinda because i i just put a uh link in
the uh
chat when we're talking about arnold
movies it reminds me of hulk hogan
and that scene from the nanny it's on
youtube i just put in both there's a guy
throwing a dog
in the background i think it's i think
it's worth taking a pause and much like
the boss rooting clip if you haven't
seen this
it is it is all time amazing what are we
doing here
just check out the link i put in the
chat if you can play it for the group
that would be pretty amazing
and we were talking doesn't need audio
uh no it doesn't need audio
okay then for sure we can do this we
were talking past root in uh
one of these last streams and someone in
the chat said he's dating boss rooting's
daughter and he's going to try
and get paul shooting on the podcast he
never got back to us we haven't heard
from him so
he probably had too many nosebears or
boss rooting could have murdered him
yeah
you do the wrong move with the boss
rootin's daughter
you're playing with the devil right
there very very possible
um what do you like it for the second
half dude
i'm just gonna hang on the uh i mean i
love my houston plus eight and a half
but
me too give me a little bit of that a
little bit of that uh
i mean i also have texans plus 250 money
line but over 26 and a half that feels
all right i'm gonna try to play this
right now okay
throw it up there on the screen all
right let's see here
yeah there we go
[Laughter]
mr nanny throwing a dog in the ocean i
love how they're like it
all right let it rip kramer it's going
first off sweet just shot there of hulk
hogan in the fu manchu
it's a classic driving with earbuds in
ahead of his time on the motorcycle
okay now just watch there oh there i
mean just beautiful
wait dude yeah you missed it no it's
right there oh it's delayed
oh okay yeah yeah okay i was watching
the i'll replay it
um yeah colby you can't watch this one
sorry dude
i it all up it's just a guy
tossing his dog into the water how does
that how does that
squeak in no i i think they just when
the editors are editing they probably
have like no idea to even look for
something in the background
but i'm sure i'm sure this wasn't
planned they just happened to be filming
when a guy happened to be throwing
his dog into the water what if it what
if it's also their only cut
that happens a lot too for something
like this they probably didn't shoot it
a ton of times yeah and they probably
didn't even notice it until like
after they watched the movie all right
management are we good
let's get it going to the second half
are we good to start
should we take one rip cream should we
should we all take a quick rip before
the
the second half what are we gonna say
real quick uh let's talk about the late
game coming on right after this
hoping to get a seven o'clock uh west
coast time story i think we should be
able to get that ten o'clock east
seahawks packers what is the line right
now over at my bookie.g
promo code tft the the opener was a bit
bigger than this packer's now
down to two and a half 47
is the total 47 and a half is the total
russell wilson
birthed a child today name
win wow
i mean if anyone's going to be allowed
to name their kid win
it's it's russell the love muscle yeah
it's going to be going to be hard to not
pick
dude seahawks we haven't seen russ since
the update i gotta give it to him
because he got rid of the luggage that
he came to the nfl with
yeah he went to sierra and went and i
heard she's got a pretty big dick
that's i'm just gonna say oh wow all
right are we ready it's urban legend
kramer
oh it could just be a lot of like a lot
of that roast beef you know
some guys are into that though that is a
disgusting act
it's like it's like a speed bag russell
wins i play college
rugby a lot of guys are into the roast
beef yeah oh yeah those guys especially
they're gross human beings
we uh we had a guy named penguin on the
team and penguin
never really played he like got he got
injured to the point where he couldn't
play and he just
but he was the guy that would routinely
piss him or himself on the couch
like late night at the party you know
here we go double screen kill
that ain't gonna work we should uh we
should give out a 25
free play kramer what are you thinking
colby what should we do
to qualify for the 25
free play over at mybookie.ag best next
next turnover
okay that works turnover
touchdown you say when the chiefs have
the ball most creative answer for what
andy reid had for the lunch
it's gonna be tough to grade yeah yeah
that's a lot to do
how about this damian williams with the
carry loses one third and eight
yeah we should just do an anytime we'll
do a turnover or a touchdown shot
next turnover or touchdown we will be
giving out a twenty-five dollar free
play
courtesy of my bookie daddy g promo code
tft and all things comedy
mahomes out of the shotgun third and
eight oh offsides when he gets back
from their own
plenty of time oh there it is and we got
a completion to sami watkins
down to the 44. semi-watkins is really
dominating the center of the field he's
he's working those deep in cuts good up
for salmon
watkins a staple of the andy reid
offense shawn remembers michael vick
with those seven step drops throwing
those deep
in cuts sexual chocolate is shown on the
blackjack table
he is got a good hand going i was just
reading about ben simmons uh shooting
three pointers
out of the shotgun completes it uh
yeah nice there we go did you see did
you hear that uh three
the one that like they're it's so quiet
in the in the
in the arena you just hear that like
double rim go kung kong
oh yeah ben simmons i mean imagine being
that
you play basketball every day sit your
ass in a gym
i shoot three second to five mahomes out
of the shotgun
completes it sami watkins that's what
i'm talking about he's activating ladies
it looks like they made a halftime
adjustment to get sami watkins involved
and they're doing that early enough in
here in the second half
sexual person 10 from the 31. shout out
to
pride films over on youtube shout out to
the city of san francisco
most human feces on the sidewalk per
capita
wow play action mahomes gets low
delivers
the ball he's got the one he's at the
one thank god that's great for the under
touchdown
wow kudos to mahomes wow he's gonna get
another rushing touchdown hanging in the
pocket and getting rid of that shot
though
i i'd like to see the review he seems
down he seems to
seem to just run it he's fire right now
throw it
molly's out of the shotgun first one
just hard count
throw it back to throw throw it get
there you got him right get there
right there
oh my god what a weird he dropped it
it's incomplete oh my god i was about to
announce the intercept
or the touchdown jesus all right i have
to compose myself
children may be watching
second and goal at the one come on bro
that's what happens when you get a half
a bill
you start playing like nick
foles nick balls is pretty awesome dude
there we go oh
edward hillary gets pushed back but
stays on his feet
gets into the end zone guys score a
touchdown mahomes still with zero
passing touchdowns i love it man that's
great i'm on that
and that's already a quick seven for the
chiefs and good for euro over two
which was 26 and a half great for the
over 47 and a half that myself
the kramer gang and the goat beau vice
have
extra points up and it's good he's
saying la has the most no actually
they're
they're i'll find i'll find the story
there's a there was a story about some
company that started tracking
reports like police public reports of
human feces and they
they heat mapped them but they poo
mapped it they made it brown
and san francisco was like the darkest
color dude but i saw the most
screwed up story this past year like
someone on hollywood boulevards walking
like a tourist
i think it was a woman and i guess a
homeless person just
had a bunch of their feces in a pan and
just
threw it right on her face wow imagine
checking out la for the first time
in this game just getting that this oh
sorry it was just for san francisco
that's why i thought san francisco
wasn't mine you see what you look at
this i'm gonna post it in the
this is great i'll i'll post it in the
uh chat here
i will say last time we did we we were
up there remember that
we saw some like some weird on the
in the uber ride
san francisco yeah san francisco gets
wild right
i'm not even trying to talk juke
move i used to go up there for work
pretty regularly monthly and in the mile
walk
from like union square wherever i was
staying out to
more like embarcadero like by the water
i i would at least one time in a trip
i'd see a guy
on the sidewalk it went from
like
it went from like oh that's weird to
like oh yeah i saw the same guy taking
the again
mahomes under center first and ten from
thirty-one
there it is that's awesome that is not
fels however we just had a touchdown
guys which means we
we are going to be giving away 25 free
play over at mybookie.eg
sending a uh a photo over at gambling
podcast on twitter of your setup of you
watching the game
maybe you're drinking on something maybe
you got the two screen experience
whatever it is your little setup
send that in and uh we'll pick one to
give a 25
my bookie free play that is tweet us
at gambling podcast
a little worried about the third quarter
understand i appreciate how like
kramer's always involved with these
stories
you know what i mean like he got a
monkey he's drawn to
a monkey at the san diego zoo hit him
with him with
mahom or watson under center second
and nine midfield
back to throw and there's david fell boy
just needs one more to push his total i
all right yeah so i've been i've had
monkeys throw at me at the san
diego zoo
i've also been on a plane that was um
emergency landed in the middle of the
country kansas city of all places
uh because a dog and threw up so
much they ran out of cleaning supplies
[Applause]
i think they might actually go for it
here maybe i'm crazy
they're down four at their home for er
at the chief's 43.
perfect time to go for it damn they're
gonna kick a 60-yard field goal this is
a horrible
half from the left hash
it's up wow that's got a lot of legs
good
you missed it the
the third quarter under lives showing
the live number over at mybookie.ag
use that promo code tft for the football
tournament
seven chiefs minus seven texans plus 200
on the money line
50 is the total so we're we're trending
back up from
when the kramer gang bought at the low
point 47. you're welcome mahomes under
center
hands it off to damian williams tackled
immediately
he's going to go way over 10 rushes
picks up one how many catches this fells
damian williams was his over under
carries 10
yeah that was edward solaire his was
nine and a half
okay they're both on pace for over what
was your question fellas has three right
he's four four needs one to push two is
it four
yeah or three chat conferences mahomes
added the shotgun
completes it michael hardman
i got 62 and a half
what's he on now 37 okay
i should have taken the receptions it's
looking like because his receptions was
five
i guess if he gets two catches he's
probably going over right 25 yards two
catches
makes sense to me about the same yeah
lines moving 50 and a half and seven and
a half now
mahomes out of the shotgun first and ten
from the 37.
oh bullet just a straight dart cover
two-beater
straight dart to travis kelsey this
dance like
every time you don't have to do the same
jig bro i can't stand him dude
in real life like kelsey bro he's one of
the most annoying players in all of
jason kelly you see jason kelsey dressed
up like a beach umbrella in a
tropical drink that parade
looking like a clown mahomes out of the
shotgun first and ten from the thirteen
completes it's the tyranny he's sure oh
they're giving him the touchdown
sean the first and third quarter under
his not
not not doing well there's a passing
touchdown but
the first one six minutes left to go in
the third i'll take that
imagine having over 16 for the chiefs in
the second half sean
kramer gang is feeling really relaxed
right now we know where this game is
going
extra points up and it's good so we
already have 14 second half points
over 26 and a half feels pretty good
yeah beauvise we're golden baby
we only need 11. well i think we have a
uh
i think we have a winner in our setup
contest the guy appears to be at work as
a security guard
and he wrote out in a sheet shout out
sports gambling podcast now pay me
that's uh that's uh i'm guessing that's
this guy pride films over on youtube
i'm guessing that as well
congratulations pride films
yeah you won a 25 free play over at
mybookie.ag
hell yeah love that kind of passion bro
yeah hopefully nothing gets stolen while
you're watching this
who says he's not involved this feels
like a legit inside job
you got an alibi now yeah there was a
security guard
uh back in the day that used to kind of
work work my dad's warehouse from time
to time and he would say
it's not my job to stop anything i'm
just here for eye candy
[Laughter]
texans with a little bit of a return
dude i i saw
you know la is just wild i walked into
ralph's one day which is like
the equivalent of safeway or standard
grocery store it's a standard grocery
store and uh
and a security guys trying to get a
homeless guy out and
he's going around the the vegetable
aisle
he runs through another aisle grabs a
can of beans throws it at the
security guard out of the shotgun first
and ten
well oh
duke johnson huge hole gets the outside
in the first down you're right
fuller is back 12-yard pickup first and
ten so so this one security guy's
chasing him around for like five minutes
and then
the the guy makes a dash for the other
door and the other security guard lets
him go out
so it's like this other dude busted his
ass the whole time yeah and the other
security guy did absolutely nothing yeah
hitting the head
like chasing a fly to get out of the
wind you're just you wanted to go out
the window so you're not gonna stop it
from going out of the window
[Applause]
watson under center play action
this time checks it down to aikens and
and that's what's going to tackle that's
one of my favorite parts of
the big lebowskis when he gets he gets
picked up by the malibu police
and uh all he's got is his ralph's club
do you have any other form of
identification
whoa careful man i got a beverage
second to nine from the 49.
who's abiding in the chat watson under
center second to nine from their own 49
loan back oh my god
what the was that we're incomplete
where's the watson interception that
comes later on the hail mary you gotta
extend for that white out
no but dude he was again watson has that
issue where he misses the easy throw
sometimes he makes these great
like crazy athletic plays but then a
layup like that you just got to hit that
guy
shout out to tino he's back
play action oh wow
there we go baby what the are we
putting with the pushing
with the unnecessary jump and dive but
it works
first down into five for 32. into kansas
city oh maybe he did need a jump that
was just
just felt like a weird animation there
then uh sean you talked over me but tino
is back his phone died and he was at
target
so we were wondering where tina went
thanks tino for checking in
oh oh no oh my god watson with a huge
run down to the 15.
it's like 35 yards and that's big for
his over 73 and a half he's completely
reeled it back in from
the very underwhelming 13 yards or
whatever he had in the first half
yeah if you bet it's over it was looking
horrible now it's looking way better
watson out of the shotgun first and 10
from the 15.
hard count
hands it off to duke johnson junior
slides around picks up uh
five four yards call it second and six
and again
get those symbol squares tomorrow night
seven o'clock pacific
we will be broadcasting the super bowl
of this simulated playoff
and uh giving away 500 are you kidding
me
just for watching the video game
oh wow that's ahead of the shotgun
second and six has time
bells got it
but garrett over on twitch i think he
was speaking to you when he said you
need to look at the picture he tweeted
in
oh yes i don't like it at all i think
it's very disrespectful
for daisy perhaps no it's it's pretty
sweet garrett we'll get you another 25
free play for that watson looks to
scream
what are you doing now what what do you
do yeah
make it one score again and we're still
covering about a half and and that
yeah i was gonna say you're you're uh
wait we're on the same side no no i'm on
i took the eight and a half good
yeah andy reid i just can't get over how
skinny he got made in this game
now an easy field goal for the texans
25-yarder from the right hash it's up
and it's good
cutting it to an eight-point game but
texans got to convert in some of these
redzone things come on
oh wow garrett apparently garrett chino
over in the twitch
is a straight-up pre-play god
how so well has one god to another hey
my
tip of the cap sir tip of the cap
he he's sending a photo it's great i
mean it's not great
you have to see it over at gambling
podcast and of course we're checking out
the
pride uh pride of films who's clearly
working has
had some sort of security desk uh
garrett sent in a photo where he had
sean and kramer and a giant pile of
money on my side and some coors lights
i'm not sure i understand oh my goodness
the old silver bullet
[Applause]
i like beer texans kicking off
24-6 cavanaugh over here i like beer and
keep sending those pictures
keep sending those pictures in because
these entries are good all night right
sean
yeah we'll draw some more winners what
are we doing another uh
25 on a yeah i just i'm just encouraging
people to continue to send these
pictures in
sean's manning the retweet booth over
there he's got two
two responsibilities the drone strike
button and the retweet
hands it off to edward to layer the
lineman what is he nothing there
seventh carry the games of kramer
maybe he gets the 10. i didn't do it
next uh next turnover or touchdown
giving out another 25
free play give us a follow on twitter
gamblingpodcast check us out on
instagram as well
bunch of fun mlb fight videos yeah these
are great
sports gaming podcast is the place to be
mahomes out of the shotgun second and
ten from his 25 checks it down
underneath
what was what was going on there be cole
hardman
not not a ton there with the run but
still picks up seven
call it third and three
and so what do we have 17 points so far
in the second half kramer
need to get to uh need nine and a half
more big play here
play action homes heating up gets it
complete to kelsey breaks the tackle
into texas territory again at the 47
dude that play
should be crazy sean because the dn the
lefty end he was right there he got
in and then he started blocking for him
look look he's blocking four mahomes
absolutely
big shout out to beer says team somo won
i just got two four packs of prankster
from target i haven't heard of that
mahomes
easy pitching catch to watkins down to
the 28.
the offense is clicking i'm a bit
concerned
cheats chong 420 saying this is boring
[Applause]
all you need to do is light up some of
that sweet ganja place the bed over at
my bookie.g using promo code tft and it
will be
very very exciting i wonder what great
dane tastes like
dave's not here man watkins picks up
uh what do we got called one one yard
two second and eight watkins coming on
seven for 103.
he's having himself a game he had a
quiet first quarter too he came on
strong
second and eight from the 26.
mahomes out of the shotgun
back to throw has time bullet pass
completes it to me cole hardman's
defense is soft
he's getting mahomes is going to clear
his yardage total for sure
and i need uh hardman i need three more
yards sean
three yards three yards i'm gonna
get screwed
who do you need three yards from hardman
one more catch
you're good what do you mean mahomes out
of the shotgun first and ten from the
11. back to throw
bullet pass sami watkins gold there we
go
at the eight in my second and eight
kansas city team total
over 16. i mean as long as we don't get
a turnover
looking good turnover time turnover
loading turn over loading
let's do this bo what are you investing
the over
47 and a half money in you going player
props second and eight
holmes under center heating up hands it
off
damian williams they're running the ball
around the goal line hilarious third and
four at the five
scott bowser long time friend of the
program contributor sports gamelan
podcast
sorry not active in the chat i found a
24-hour american gladiator channel oh my
god that's awesome
i wonder if i wonder if those dudes are
still alive jesse like
is announcing those things right mahomes
out of the shotgun big third and four to
the endzone oh
my gosh huge bro are you serious
huge break for texans backers and that
and then under three touchdowns
touchdowns right huge swing there huge
yeah malibu that like uh roided out dude
with the long blonde hair the california
guy
yeah it wasn't like you're like saber
disabled chiefs uh for the field goal
making it 11-point game 27-16
but he had 20 points so far so we just
need one more touchdown to hit the
second half over feeling good about that
feeling great texans nipping at the
heels covering that eight and a half
that's well with it the back door is
open it's perfect it's a two-score game
kansas city doesn't need to play that
good of defense they can they can let
the tanks to the score
and still win this game we're feeling
good turbo that guy was awesome
no i mean and that nintendo game was
good too man america gladiators that was
a fun game
was that on nintendo or sega i they
might have done one for sex i liked back
in the day
that high speed tennis ball cannon oh
that was great that was the best event
assault is that what it was called where
he was just standing up there
like and firing down on the people it
seems so scary
was cool too though jazz is good big
nitro guy
i actually i never rooted for the
gladiators about climbing that like rock
wall
that was tough
yeah was better back in the 80s
including john elway and include yeah
yeah
john elway man i like john elwyn
i love john elway first and ten
from their own 25.
all right let's get a touchdown here
let's close this thing watson out of the
shotgun
turbo was actually his christian name
incomplete over the middle he's wide
open man
he's looked really good except he's had
like four or five horrific
throws shout out to master guts
how are 300 people still viewing this
garbage wow
because they have money on it you
i mean sorry you idiot
there you go you can't say
anymore i mean well maybe that's the new
uh
redskins uh teammate that'd be great
completes it to fells
gus ferrat qualifies for when he
headbutted a wall the washington post
himself
out of the game the washington r word
fells loses a yard but he's
he's got seven grabs for 34 yards
so he hit the over on the props texans
need to keep this drive going like come
on
watson under center with the hard count
third and eleven back to throw
pick the pressure looks to scramble give
him a block
what do you do oh my god he almost got
it
who was that he's lying that's the
second fumble of the texas
block he might get a first down can i
extremely lucky can i see one
lineman bobble a ball not just pick it
up beautifully
scoop great scoop there well we saw the
uh
in one of the early games the texans
biggest play
from the wild card weekend was uh the
lineman getting loose for a huge
bumble recovery so must be something
bill o'brien teaches in practice on
these
in these linemen so people wait
people saying the over is dead what kind
of math are you doing we're at 43.
yeah one score we're good in the second
half over what kind of over do you have
i have over 47 and a half hopefully you
would you followed the kramer game
and the advice of the the sim creator
himself
yeah by the way what's up with people
stealing soyboard do they have
t-shirts that say hashtag coleslaw i
don't think so
mahomes hands it off to edward solaire
his eighth carry the game picks up seven
second and three
bret uh glover checking in what's with
the w uh
washington state cougs hat bow down to
washington oh wow
we're watching because we're shocked to
see a cougar not working at mcdonald's
some apple cup trash talk if i ever
heard it
mahomes out of the shotgun second and
three from the 37.
hey if your coach invites us to the
campus we'll probably become coog fans
or uh husky fans yeah
i don't know i'm being honest the the if
washington cape rolovich is paying for
people's bar
tabs it's my favorite type of guy that
seems like a solid dude
watkins with the catch j.j watt getting
out in coverage
trying to strip the ball loose couldn't
do it third and two from the 38
huge play here green
out of the shotgun mahomes third and two
big play watts double team wide open to
kelsey there's backwards oh
he's short he's sure yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
for a second uh master guts
kramer can't call anyone an idiot while
wearing sunglasses and a hat backwards
indoor it's a beautiful night in kansas
city tonight hold on a second
colby i'm not done i look very cool
right now
i've been told that from his children to
the shotgun play action
default into the middle interception and
he hangs on to it it's a jump ball but
kelsey pulls it down and
uh sir please i mean this area right
here is for sale so if you are looking
to
buy some space backwards hat indoors
i never heard that one sunglasses i had
heard before now listen but sometimes
people get scared of drip
mahomes out of the shotgun
back to throw get their watt jesus
completes its retiree kill
we're gonna blow this cover on me yeah
you are holding to a field goal back
door cover that's what i'm predicting
23 30. you heard it here first
yeah shout out to my boogie man
helping helping put uh put mastic guts
in his seat
aka the locker tino smo won and youtube
atc saying
glasses and hat backwards definitely bde
yeah thank you you're welcome
you remember ken griffey jr that dude
could hit a baseball really far
he had he invented the backward hat same
with his father
edward solaire with another carry kramer
you should have met that i don't know
such a colby thing to say i'm talking
about the great ken griffey jr and colby
has to go like yeah
i like i like ken griffey before he had
a junior you know he was just a cooler
player you know
second and three mahomes out of the
shotgun from the 13.
oh another near interception god damn
that could have been huge
is that the best father-son duo ever
in baseball well there's jack elway and
john elway no no in in baseball
just being funny uh baseba and baseball
wait till tom brady's son gets the lead
yeah
i don't i don't think he uh i mean yeah
he opened mouth kisses at like a
a junior level five star recruit and by
the way
there we go fumble rip the ball out that
oh my
god changing the sack carrickton junior
talk to me better barry and shane larkin
look out
um he was a basketball player wouldn't
he yeah
miami yep jimmy laranega
who the are these people fair
question hello we're the sports gambling
podcast falcon talk
we're broadcasting some madden games
that you can bet on
and we're having a good time salud
cheers to everyone hanging out
cheers henry wilson saying how do you
guys feel about real sports being back
love it it's awesome more gambling
opportunities
yeah of course wait football's not back
until then
we're still joking september uh
sean and i are planning to kick off the
preview content in august
first week of august division previews
coming for the nfl fantasy football
previews
we already have some top 10 fantasy
football podcast episodes out
mock draft episodes you can get them all
if you subscribe to the podcast
i'm looking for that pick six as well
because i i still need i still need two
points shawn my uh my chief second half
over 16. that's come in
barry bonds and bobby bonds great answer
tino
correct answer real sports are fixed i
only bet madden and
nba 2k i love it
i can tell you i'm on the sticks
kneel it down and now the texans take
over down 14.
six minutes left to go perfect back door
opportunity
you guys betting on the nba scrimmages
henry wilson wants to know of course we
are
hashtagged and you bet on it yes yes
then yes just check out
sportsgamblingpodcast.com tons of
gambling content
advice pigs podcasts we do it all watson
out of the shotgun first and ten from
his own 25 spin move
he's looking to run putting the team on
his back nice black shield
a little bit doesn't hang on to it it
always ends up being
the honey badger second in inches get in
there block man
come on and sean i feel like i've been
stuck in my house not spending any money
on a sweet summer vacation or anything
so i have way more money in the old
my bookie account it's kind of dangerous
well
and if you want some money deposit there
use the promo the tft
100 deposit bonus watson out of the
shotgun bullet pass
they got there's some fight in this team
yet first down 5 30 left to go at
midfield
sean's wet dream back door is lubed up
ready for receiving
he's one of those guys who will get
penetration can the back door get
penetration we're about to find out 5
20 left to go texans chiefs pick six
watson out of the shotgun
pick six has time bullet
almost picked almost intercepted it
seemed like it wasn't going to fells but
he made a great play on the ball and
then dropped it
henry wilson pointing out that uh at
least the texans don't give up 48
straight points this time
they did blow a lead so again these
simulations end up being
fairly realistic
watson here in the center get off the
field
again he looks great for most of the
game and then he just has a couple
horrific throws and i actually needed to
throw an interception because i took
that uh
sweating right now throw your bets out
there i got i got i need three more
yards for hardman i don't think i'm
gonna get it
watson under center
checks it down to phil is that
just stealing catches left and right
fourth and two from the 42.
that was the play clover saying
unfortunately you can't bet
on the national anthem will we have will
one of us sing the national anthem
colby for the uh before the symbol
oh yeah we might stay tuned i'll be like
leslie nielsen in a
naked gun big fourth dad watson under
center
looks to run what are you doing god damn
it
jones i thought he was injured i think
we need a national anthem
we need to figure that out we'll figure
that out maybe we'll get carl lewis
to appear hard count
patrick mahomes random pull i formation
hands it off to jamie once he gets blown
back now the texans have
three timeouts it's not completely over
for the plus eight and a half because
they can stop kansas city here lead a
little time out the clock i think in a
weird way it almost helps them are they
in field goal range yet
no they're at their own 39 right that
would be a
78 yard line he made that field goal by
like 15 yards i feel like last time
mahomes out of the shotgun second and
thirteen another hand off there
spin moon by edward solaire and he's got
the first down jesus
he's not that good in real life and he
goes over his rushing toe
i gotta trust my gut gut never does you
wrong
the second half over is also in trouble
sean
it is what are we sitting at uh i think
we're at
20 points mahomes under center
three minutes left to go back they're
throwing it they're accepted
oh come on get the out of here you
caught that
oh my god kelsey contested crab
what am i rooting for here i need a i
need a field goal i need the over to hit
at least
i could also use a hardman catch three
yards let's go
they know it for some of these props
they know to run the clock wait if they
kick a field goal
touchdown we're not covering half don't
we
[Applause]
hands it off damian williams
they're not calling timeouts either are
they are they gonna call them after the
two-minute warning
yeah i think they're waiting here
wow field goal would be excellent
a three yard pass to hardman and then a
field goal
i don't think they're calling timeouts
sean
no they have three timeouts they're
gonna call them they're i don't think so
they would have called them already what
are you talking about why would they
wait till the two-minute warning
i don't know because they're a video
game what do you mean i don't think
they're gonna call a timeout
i think they're down by two two scores i
think they will
mahomes hands it off to damian williams
and as predicted they're gonna call a
timeout
down 14 here maybe we get a black field
goal we've seen some crazy finishes
to these madden simulations will we see
another one
watson never threw a pick either well
not yet
okay we that's why we need this stop
under center
no oh no hands up to david williams all
right
picks up one time now hardman's not
going to come in though that's that's
unfortunate
nothing good for plus eight and a half
wait john i'm already up a unit right
yeah you're about to be up three units
ryan wow
what is it what is it what's it like
being on this side of the ledger
feeling light like a cloud 42
yard field goal come on someone get in
there get in there
oh and it's okay yes watch this where a
yeah no i have the over 47.
let's go oh why would you do that
oh i appreciate him 48. one time out
let's get that back door cover oh my god
watson back to throw completes the
defels that's not what they need down to
the 39
what the keep it going keep going
no huddle
no huddle i can't even believe i i don't
even hurry up
hurry up what's happening they're
probably pick six
times regardless he's thinking about his
next sandwich
why not he's moving on to the afc
championship game
which we will be airing tomorrow night 3
p.m pacific
watson hits fuller in stride
clock continues to run 114 left to go
come on he's this guy's talking
he's down 14 with a minute
what come on go now this is where you
would have
used your timeout probably because um
they gotta cover a big distance
40 seconds left to go everyone calling
for at the 40.
everyone calling for the fight get out
of that get out of bed
he's out of bounds stops the clock 53
seconds left at the 27.
houston come on you can cover the eight
and a half and the second time
[Applause]
[Laughter]
3 p.m pacific 3 p.m pacific yes
mandarin tang it was commenting that i
mispronounced this 3 p.m specific
come on i'm excited i got money on this
thing oh and hopefully management can
get that
lined up play action bullet pass
completed the kenny still yeah
time out time out call the timeout
here's where you call the timeout
first and goal at the nine clock
continues to run 40 39 come on
what are you doing
if you come
[Applause]
because really either way they have
whatever it's
three plays one time out so the fact
that that was incomplete that's fine
because even if they complete it and
don't get in they still have the time
out to use so why is this so
why does this have to be tense i was so
relaxed earlier i was getting my
over the field goal just had to be
kicked watson
under center second to go from the nine
back to throw just get it to the end
to the end zone oh that was it time
out time
out how was this certainly dangerous
now here's the thing you cannot take a
sack and you cannot
stay in bounds 16 seconds we've seen
these madden sims
they have two shots if both shots are
into the end zone
dude are they smart enough to don't to
realize that double screen we're about
to
witness this you're watching the
football tournament presented by my
bookkeeping
fourth and goal fourth and goal from the
six
jesus that dude he was open adam
had him this is pretty intense sean i'm
very sad though cause i know how this is
gonna end
already trying to reverse jinx we'll see
if it can work
fourth and goal from the six 12 seconds
left to go watson with the hard count
back to throw get into the end zone
[Applause]
you know what i lost that eight and a
half
in the second half over but that was
such a rush i don't even care
[Applause]
man tell me that didn't feel like real
gambling
tell me why that didn't make you feel
alive
tell me that didn't make you want to go
to my bookie.g
promo code tft and load up with some
more money
money money money make sure you get in
your
super bowl squares they are filling up
for the symbol
tomorrow night sportsgamblingpodcast.com
squares well sean we're not going
anywhere we're not going anywhere i know
you were you were doing your clothes out
the show thing and i'm like oh
i'm closing out this game got to remind
sean all right
we're riding right into the next game
colby's going to hit the camera
colby's got a piss huh got 14 minutes to
go
yeah we're we'll we'll estimate uh we'll
let
my bookie madden tell us if they need
the start time push back at all but
right now we're saying 7 p.m on the west
coast is gonna be the next game
yep we're good well
of course we're good we're always good
man what a ride
[Music]
i mean i knew the chiefs minus four
ka-ching
chiefs minus two eight and a half
didn't get my player pro i went one in
one of the player props sean so
yeah i hit the fells prop and uh frankly
i feel like me and beau vice got robbed
on the over 47 and a half
your second half over did not come in no
but i hit
let's take a look at the problem sean
watson over one and a half
passing touchdowns did not get that but
i got the
under on my homes passing touchdowns i
think everyone
i think they both went over all their
they they both went over everything but
they're passing props
they're touchdowns yeah and then desean
watson
did not go over his rushing prop
or his rushing attempts or his rushing
tds so not a rushing day for day none of
the none of the running backs
fared well um oh the dice i'm sorry the
chiefs running backs all went over
they went over their yardage and their
rushing attempts and their touchdown
sean
these were plus odd touchdown props i
think plus 200
the receivers look at phelps just
absolute lock there over
five receptions i don't think he went
over his yardage either
no i don't think he got short kelsey
absolutely i mean kelsey and watkins
were the guys to go after
will fuller as well hardman got over the
receptions not the yardage
unfortunately stills uh stills i feel
like stills got there as well a lot of
overs in the passing games today he got
over both ways
cooks did not sean neither did tyree
kill
did get in the end zone though so you uh
dabbled in the new touchdown props
you uh you probably fared pretty well
yeah especially those rushing ones i
touched i gave out but did not have the
cojones the back of myself
all right i'll leave this open i'll let
i'll let management let me know when
they're good with the numbers
[Music]
whoa what a game and now and that's the
thing
whenever we're broadcasting these games
i don't know what it is but there's just
excitement in the air
and now we know the afc championship
will be
in baltimore maryland the baltimore
ravens will be hosting the kansas city
chiefs
8 p.m on the east coast 5 pm on the west
coast approximately
later they'll be the second game in the
triple header tomorrow
saturday where we're starting of course
3 p.m on the west coast 5 pm
on the or 6 p.m on the east coast with
the nfc championship shown
so that's what andy reed was thinking
about with about a minute left those
crab cakes huh early early take i
don't know what the number uh
oh they're saying they're preparing the
line for the afc championship right now
what do you think it's going to be
sean what if you're making the line what
are you making
is kansas city favorite on the road they
have to be right
probably yeah harry city minus three
i think it's like kansas city i think
it'll be a pick
i think that's what the afc championship
game will end up closing at
i think they'll start it off because
people love taking the
the chiefs in these sims they'll
probably start it off at two and a half
minus
minus two and a half minus three
but we'll see where things settle down
and man that's gonna be exciting
well now six six plus hours of straight
sims tomorrow night
and now i'm up three units on you sean
i'll i'll of course show
i'll show the sliders again let's see
what time what time does uh
man my bookie madden are we good for a 7
p.m start
i'll show the sliders again for the uh
for all the
diamonds and fugazis out there garrett's
asking you to
sean to check your twitter dm these guys
i mean what guys trying to slide into
our demons jesus man
only if it's arousing should you slide
into our dms
all right i don't know why people give a
about this
snoop dogg man i gotta turn this
down
get us in trouble
the free plays take a little bit to hit
so just stay stay tuned
yeah i'm telling kramer to send them
over
they'll get them when they get it we got
a lot going on over here uh
shout out to iverson1 for for he
recommended to you kramer
a great minds think i like because i
didn't see your actual comment but on
the same page
what did he say on the watson over
oh the interception yeah all credit to
him that was not that was not me
uh and just so you know i have i have
sent over the free plays so all right
and so we're at the mercy of the uh the
suits
back in the office you know you know
what i'm saying
corporate america yeah you know well and
sean now
as i was stating before i do have the
pick i'm now up three units
you are you're getting hot i'm looking
at a situation sean i don't know if you
are you looking at the line
do you have an updated number because
last we saw it was down to two and a
half and i was fully prepared to take
the four and a half
when it was seattle plus four and a half
but it's not that anymore
let me pull this up
uh i mean russell wilson had a kid named
win will he be distracted by the recent
birth of his child for this kid's name
is
divisional round playoff game here's the
thing
at the end of the day colby yes picked
on d
what is the ultimate tiebreaker in this
game always
take the team that has the sh
hitman bobby wagner any of these guys
who have fully equipped
drone strike systems in their arsenal
sean if you could come with you
give me a drone strike please because
this is what bobby wagner does
you're 100 right and that sound can only
mean one thing i'm going to take
seahawks plus two and a half
i'm with you i'm with you man you don't
change horses midstream
what that sound means is we've activated
the bobby
wagner forced fumble oh it's gonna
happen forced it has to be a turnover
forced fumble giveaway oh 25
free plays again send in those pictures
at gamblingpodcast
on twitter of your setups where are you
watching
the football tournament what are you
getting into again
always a bonus if you include a spouse
preferably female but any sort of spouse
that is watching this game with you
uh including them in the photos always
good uh nose beers
regular beers mgs
yeah and i am going to update the
tourney leaderboard as we're getting
here
first thing first though we're going to
figure out the outfits for the next game
colby's favorite part oh i mean look do
we mess with the pack so you're saying
you're locking in
the clc so i'm on the packers minus two
and a half
i'm fine with that packers team they can
get hot
i'm gonna back i'm gonna back the
seahawks here man wagner wagner's an
animal he really is and then i hate
going against him
well let's look at some of these props
cause there's a ton of fun props over at
my bookie daddy g promo code tft
sean why don't you do that while i get
organized over here so of course do the
uh
first and third quarter under that's uh
at nine and a half
both first and third lock that up
it's an auto play what are the numbers
today sean
nine and a half thank you you're welcome
russell wilson over 242 and a half i
think i think pretty low play
that's a play i'll tell you this seattle
team can get higher pretty interesting
cole did you want to mess with this at
all uh
no the packers are classic don't don't
do that no we don't do those right
definitely don't do that brown helmets
yeah um
who wants the highlighters no man yeah i
don't get these throwbacks they're
pretty gross
that's pretty good right yeah we just go
classic it's a classic right there
that makes you think it's good ray
nitschke all right
there's always a lot of debate seahawks
have like three different very very
different
unis i'm tempted to just go straight
modern day
that's fine not not that no we're not
doing that we have a rule if you're the
road team you're oh the all whites are
always nice though
yeah i like them we could do that that's
great great let's go gray
we'll need approval from sean is gray
close enough to white
oh wait green bay's white no no i'm
saying oh yeah instead of white
using neon gray
all right i already found my lock prop
sean was doing work alan lazard oh over
five and a half this is easy
he's the david falls of this package
have we seen either of these teams
recently
no and so maybe they update it and it's
not involved al i'm going big on alan
lazar
al lazard over one and a half touchdowns
that's plus 300
loving him there so you're telling me
you're not taking wilson over 242 and a
half
that's probably good but i'm not
touching because i'm on the packers russ
oh my goodness sternberger is always
interesting but five and a half feels a
hair high
for uh for the stupid package
no that's that's the play is it really
five and a half yeah you know what yeah
so give me lazard
at uh what was what did i say
well metcalf over 61.
maybe we play this differently and we
just go sternberger over 56 and a half
no i'm going lizard and sternberg are
both over all right i'll go with you
sternberger
over five and a half for the kramer gang
i'll take it for you i'll take lazard
okay dominant lizard um what are you
doing throw out what you guys like in
the uh prop bets
yeah and influence us please what do you
think about metcalf over 61 and a half
he i i don't know how to bet this
seahawks prop
market honestly i i think i i'd like to
play
carson's had some good games i don't i
don't want to mess around with the
the you know what let's do metcalf over
sixty one and a half yards right
wait four and a half catches four and a
half catches over four and a half
catches over the sixty one and a half
okay
well let's do both let's do both over
four and a half catches for metcalf
and over 61 and a half yards
oh jesus how am i supposed to also first
touchdown
oh yeah let's let's do one of those too
i'm not gonna get cute i got cute last
time
bit me in my ass i'm going aaron jones
plus 500.
five to one that's a that feels like a
great bet hmm
well russell wilson plus 600 that's
intriguing well
and if you're if you're new to first
touchdown bets when it has the
quarterback there it means a run
it means a run uh you know what let's go
all in on dk metcalf plus
1400 john first touchdown dk metcalf
plus 1400 first touchdown
i'm gonna ride i'm gonna ride tyler lock
lockett
um kramer people are feeding in the chat
room for my bookie
dot ag promo code tft to get these bets
credited do not worry
we will not start this next game until
your your action is graded
because i'm assuming a lot of these guys
are just going to be laying they're
they're wanting to take their winnings
on that first game and roll it over to
late game so don't worry guys
we will give you time to roll those bets
over
oh dr jamie jakes in the atc youtube
saying carson over
58 and a half okay he's had some good
games man
that's not a bad angle i feel like i'm
playing a little bit with fire
because i don't know we have not seen
either one of these teams since the last
couple updates and
the defense of special teams touchdown
being six to one
with bobby wagner out there i'm sorry is
that just any defensive special teams
touchdown
okay it's six to one i mean if you if
you see how they price it at the super
bowl it's usually like 300 400. so six
to one well they know bobby wagner
i feel like there's some value though
that that feels kind of high at six to
one
yeah yeah and i i i think we'll we'll
push the start time back in this game
make sure everyone gets their bets in
we'll be good don't worry guys
everyone calm down we will get you
covered and uh why don't you do us a
favor subscribe to the podcast
sports gambling podcast and get those uh
get those super bowl squares in
so you can have your chance at winning
500 in the symbol tomorrow night
7 p.m and of course afc championship
game already set
it's going to be chiefs at ravens
3 p.m pacific then 5 p.m pacific the nfc
championship game
where the winner of this game will move
on to the nfc championship game and then
7 p.m the symbol
i think you yeah the afc championship
second sean but that you got that
you've corrected me twice on that kramer
because when i had it second before you
said no that's the wrong thing
no definitely not i'm looking at it
right now i have colby confirm that i've
been looking at this the entire time no
but when we did the podcast previously
you said when i
when i said it was nfc first you said i
was wrong
the nfc is first you were right okay so
uh you were wrong to correct me the
first time
magic man blanco sends us a photo with
some decaf nose beard oh he's ready to
go yeah
some tequila put that on the instagram
called some beer
i mean just kidding oh and my bookie
matt
we've just opened the afc championship
wow what is it at
minus three and a half 53 and a half is
the total
chief's chiefs wrote favorites at three
and a half yep
okay i think there's i think there's
some value at that hopefully you have
the pick
john we're gonna see hopefully you get a
pick back because i
really really the best value is signing
up for those super bowl squares because
it's
is that literally that's great right
everything we do is free
oh you know what i've been staring at
that wilson over one and a half you know
let's do it wilson over one and a half
passing touchdowns that just feels dirty
how low it is
right no he just had a kid named win
russell's gonna win baby all right i'm
getting too exposed here
imagine your name is wynn wilson what a
weird name
uh philly's just grounded out with two
on they're all right
but that's why we're watching this game
season's over yeah r.i.p baseball
[Laughter]
shawn's moved on to the sixers yep
sexer's gonna like them for two weeks
until
football the national football league
magic man blanco checking in and uh we
have a bottle of jameson up for grabs
he challenged me that the packers would
have more wins than my eagles the eagles
of course lost their first game
packers now uh well they you could push
i guess yes if packers lose here
oh wait no packers already won their
first game right so they had to buy
oh you're right this is i was trying to
do this at first
this is their first game in the playoffs
and uh
so if they lose here i don't have to
send him a bottle of whiskey no you
would push and i'm gonna i'm updating
the leaderboard right
as we speak sean okay doing so many
things
has uh
yeah my booky madden's gonna let us know
when we're ready to go
seahawks are taking this he's got
russell wilson has the blitz radar
yeah but it's really bobby wagner like
that's the x to me that's the reason
at the end of the day i'm taking them
aaron rodgers is a gambler got it like
that
top corner gambler yeah i like that
i don't know what he's gambling on
unprotected sex maybe
oh god what
uh not that there's anything wrong with
that i don't know man
you wear a raincoat in the shower
all right i'm going to grab a beer i'll
be right back we will be kicking off
here pretty soon
yeah and sorry i'm uh i'm updating the
leaderboard you have another premium
light beverage
oh wow as the kids as shawn
shawn walking into the studio with the
giant thing of corona
the kids are just like oh my god shawn's
bringing corona into the house like joe
jesus
what's tasteless the children what does
uh biftan say in like uh back to the
future
i wish i yeah come over to your house
all you got for me is light light and
fear
i if only we could have that that man's
uh
documentation say hello to your mother
for me mcfly
all right what's everyone got they're
alright your bets i i want maybe there's
something else i missed
that i need to get in on uh it's not the
first time that i've
i'll follow i'll be a follower instead
of a leader
did you take you didn't you didn't take
my wilson over 243
yeah all right hold on i gotta finish
updating the
wilson over 243
and a half let's see what it is live
that's a good bet
it is tell me you saw this post
oh my god i mean again i the to have the
cojones to name your child
win you got to respect russell wilson
for that right
uh i mean just just legend sure you you
got a man crush on him a little bit
though
wilson no on russell but probably
he's the love he's the love muscle well
he's on one
at uh here's the real question when does
she
see you sean can get real dark uh losing
when he's gambling and if if he starts
slipping down to five
seven units i think we have to keep an
eye on him yeah you gotta watch
but i will say like if you've never
watched the seattle sim game
bobby white just keep just watch bobby
wagner he is gonna separate some
from the ball
and people want me to be angry so i mean
should i pick the packers then
no no no what what what people were
saying they want me to know
angry i like when you're happy better
don't we don't want colby to be
see the chat's real filled with
negativity that's the kind of i
hate about the chat
they want to see us fight they want to
see the worst of us
[Laughter]
i don't want to see that and as oh that
that's it that's how good i am
leaderboard's updated over at
sportsgamblingpodcast.com
i'll drop the link in here colby
yeah sean is walking over here soon he
didn't spill any beer we have to be
close
uh-oh he didn't spill any beer is he
spilling beer again
so far so good he's he's made it this
far
he's like right now he's like rudiger at
holy cross you know
he's right across the way he's working
hard he's working hard he's he's
painting helmets the team is is turning
in jerseys
you know oh oh and he and he's and he
gets in
on the final play of the game and vince
vaughn
gives him a high five for being a dick
you would have
so lazard over five and f catches that's
my big prop
and then i also threw sternberger over
five and a half
and uh and i'm jones first touchdown
plus 500. and i've been told the free
plays from the first game are in the
accounts
wow crammers next level i'm doing a lot
of over here the leaderboard got
updated
uh we're we're just moving and shaking
shout out to dick
gertsberger who has now signed in and
he's here now national tequila day he
says long
he hates it whoa dick you should
hop
over to the atc youtube channel and
introduce yourself tequila is a
beautiful invention man
come on you gotta look all right what's
everyone got in the atc chad
what's everyone leaning into where are
the bets at
please provide your uh identification
aka
betslip look follow dundee to the land
down under seahawks are taking this one
i got i look i know i steered you the
wrong but we're at the three yard line
yeah you know hey even though you lost
money on it that
that uh that was worth the ride that was
fun i don't regret anything on that bet
kramer got no rush out of his bed sean
will when are we picking the squares
well we're obviously going to pick the
squares
in the lead up to the big game we we we
think the game is probably going to be
closer to uh like a
727 732 kickoff like they like to do and
the big boys yeah because there's going
to be any time to grade of course
we won't even know the team's playing in
the game until right before
a lot of ends a lot of outs and then i
believe we're going to get all the props
so
the the gap will probably be good for
you but that's when we're also gonna
draw squares we're gonna do a brat toast
we're gonna pop some nose beard and some
decaf nose beards
gonna do it all uh i mean it's
it's on all
has everyone had their bets graded
come on seahawks i like how people get
mad that they grade losses first
that's what i would do right yeah
all right you always start at the
beginning of the rainbow colby
you would always start at a rainbow dude
you know peace and love peace and love
i can't wait to i i just can't wait to
get back
off the grid i'm escaping blue light
again next weekend
did you get you chasing rainbows again
i'm i mean i think this time i'm i'm
i have a super i have a super edible i'm
planning on
i'm going to do 100 mg wow uh
stargaze well hell you don't need to you
don't need to
go off the grid to do that dude i want
to do it safely
and then where i'm going the worst thing
that can happen is i walk into the ocean
that's pretty bad the ocean's like the
most mysterious place on the
planet
if you slept walked into the ocean you
would float back to shore
i don't know man didn't it dude just
didn't the wwf wrestler just die
in venice beach for going out in the
ocean i i mean maybe but could he not
swim
no he was out there with his son he's
one of these guys who can't can't wipe
his own ass he's a real muscle man you
want to be 100 milligrams in and deal
with a riptide
well exactly that's the perfect state of
mind to be
in him for a riptide because you're not
supposed to fight it you need to relax
let it pull you out and let the rib take
once once it calms down you just swim
back to shore
head over to thailand or that yeah i
mean
that's a real rip current but all right
let's get it going
let's get this game going let's get some
action
yeah i'm wait i i think we're waiting on
the uh
people still waiting on grades i did
mushrooms in a hurricane once it was
really fun so maybe you're right maybe
maybe you're on to something
mushrooms during a hurricane yeah dcu
had a hurricane come through
everything was boarded up just me and
some friends had a bunch of mushrooms
went walking around town it got pretty
trippy when when
when the uh like a lot of the trees were
almost like bent over
i don't know if that was that the
mushrooms or the wind i'm saying i don't
recall i don't know it's all merging
together but it was definitely it got a
little weird
but it was fun it was fun all right
i've been told i'm i'm gonna call uh
yeah we've been told a couple more
minutes
okay so let's hear more about this
coleslaw sandwich
listen i have what was the inspiration
behind this had you had one pr
previously well i i was i was
it was one of those moments in my life
where i'm like well i can cheat
or i can act like i'm doing something
while everyone's watching
and so i was like i'm gonna do it and in
hindsight
it was a bad choice well yeah i mean i
still get but
but here's the message here's the thing
you are acting like we had
a five-star spread all right
look shout out to washington state
peace and love all that nice stuff i
enjoyed my time there i'm gonna kick a
47 yard field goal up there
all right god willing they have me back
after i say what i'm about to say
but y'all are the coleslaw was one of
the finest pieces of the spread i'll say
no what do you mean i'll say that that
was nice they did a bunch of like chips
little salad option it wasn't it wasn't
crazy hot dogs and hamburgers hot dogs
hamburgers but pulled pork
was the delicacy there that was their
treat to you
and we're sitting in the uh announcing
booth and you guys are acting like
cheering who knew who knew absolute
cavemen apparently you're not allowed to
cheer in the press box we got yelled at
a couple times for that but we had we
had money on the
on the game and uh so colby and i
enjoy these delicious pulled pork
sandwiches in the press box
and kramer comes back with a a bun just
full
of coleslaw instead of meat the thing is
if you're trying
if you're on a diet and a white flour
bun with coleslaw in the middle it's not
nutritious there's cameras everywhere
there's people everywhere i got a
feeling like
they're going to think about inviting us
this year and they're going to go to the
athletic director and she's like
a tape back are those guys i think that
that that what was that thing like
was coleslaw sandwich we were the
coolest there
all right we were the only ones there
that mike leach was
was hawking our show dude luckily leech
hopefully leach didn't find out
that might have been the reason why he
left at mississippi state these
people in washington
and by the way sandwiches that's when
soyboy was created
not when when it was copied let's not
forget
all right sounds like people are getting
graded
let's get it going this is the
the last game of the divisional round of
the football tournament
presented by the sports gaming podcast
mybookie.g promo code tft
and of course our good friends over at
all things comedy
let's get it going crazy that sweet
sweet post yeah
russell wilson with his daughter win
just loving life getting ready for this
game
now again the chalk continues sean real
quick
warning warning we're about to watch a
simulated game we're fine with it
bring on the sims will we have wind in
lambeau
i could really alter these props all
right are we ready
i'm ready let's get it going let's
boogie and remember even if you miss out
on the on the
bets before the game there is in-game
wagering
all all game long over at mybookie.ag
promo code tft
dylan uh in the atc youtube chat with a
hot take
aaron rodgers is gonna win mvp this
upcoming season you heard it here
first that is a uh that's a bold take
maybe if he does a commercial for the
brat step i could see him
winning mvp then well if he likes that
bet
i know i'm pulling up the odds over at
my boogie dot ag that's
they got a pretty good price on oh these
uh this uniform combination might be our
best yet
packers will start with the ball first
and ten from their own 25.
the throwback packers with the against
the gray it looks like the e we're on
evil
it looks like we've bet on evil kobe
beautiful beautiful stadium this is
where football games should be played
let's go
rogers under center first and ten from
zone 25
hands it off
this is football no i agree it's a great
stadium but it's every super bowl
they should just rotate between soldier
and and lambo and maybe arrowhead
just go to all three and just rotate now
you're forgetting the link in
philadelphia
yeah you know i like veterans you're
talking about great veterans
was the first to have a jail i'm more of
a veteran stadium guy aaron rodgers
hands it off to aaron jones
[Applause]
he escaped the first drone strike of the
game
look once a corporation gets behind it i
don't i
i'm not i'm not on board lambo soldier
arrowhead will always be great because
they're them third and six from their
own 29.
lambo looks like someone landed a
spaceship on top of it dude i was there
in december
amazing stadium roger's out of
the pistol
back to throw spin move down heating up
there we go oh plus 600 oh no
there we go diggs with the early pick
cuckoo
packers off to a a rough start here
they'll take over in packers territory
at the 27.
hand it off to carson oh that's rashad
penny
picks up start shout out to penny our
gals
san diego state magic man blanco yes i
have been to lambeau
that would have been a fun uh a fun
first score huh that would have been
not as fun as metcalf let's go fourteen
to one baby
i might have i might have put a you know
wilson out of the shotgun second to nine
i'm on lock it hands it off
penny again with the carry
picks up four third and five for the
seahawks
really going to take advantage of this
early turnover in green bay territory i
didn't take the over
half interception with rogers this time
i i god damn it
ice iverson in our uh twitch page is
just loving it right now
easy cash yeah i mean that must have
been plus odds i have to
wilson heart count out of the shotgun
third and five back to throw
damn chicks plus a thousand to score
just screwing a touchdown at all our
first touchdown first touchdown what do
we got here let me pull up the props
person go up to five seahawks on the
move oh my goodness
so right back to it first touchdown
russell wilson six to one carson eight
to one
lock it ten to one metcalf 14 to one
door set 16. lock it in the slot here
olson tillerson out of the shotgun hands
it up okay
nothing there they love to run the ball
offense
one day they're going to figure it out
they really do is it raining or is they
are someone just glowing
i don't think it's raining we've never
seen rain how many milligrams deep are
you
doesn't it look like he's glowing
oh man split eye wilson under center
second goal it's going to five
where's metcalf he's not even on the
field
hands it off to carson oh no it's a
touchdown that's a touchdown
sean you're on the right path you want
wrong team chris
i was thinking of taking carson if i was
on the seahawks i would have is he
down early can we challenge he rolls he
rolls over the body
yeah elbow elbow down no no big fat guy
underneath him
i have the seahawks so i shouldn't
complain that was quick that was a quick
score
yeah seahawks out to an early seven
nothing lead shout out to geno smith
with that perfect hold
if anyone's a lone shark out there uh
hit up at shaun t
green on twitter he's gonna need some uh
financial assistance
his gym hidden gems saying on the uh atc
youtube you're watching a fake game get
a life losers oh no we're broadcasting a
fake game
and we are we are this is a life we're
having uh
we're making some wagers enjoying
ourselves having a couple cocktails
you ever watch a fake movie you
huh
[Applause]
over the top wow colby coming at him oh
am i not let's say
seahawks up seven nothing here 11
minutes
left to go i mean look we're not aligned
and you're you're you're
thinking sir now that being said
i i love the people that come watch the
game and then make fun of people
watching i can't say i got to
make a note of that
say the artwork yeah or say stupid yeah
no one gets mad if you call someone
stupid whatever happened to jackass is
that okay can i say jackass
i would say um i like knucklehead you
could also use hand jobs
knucklehead makes me seem like start
using hand job hand job's great yeah
just start calling people hand jobs
bringing a hand job back
yeah first and ten from their own 35
sean you got to be worried they already
have a turnover and it wasn't a bobby
wagner-induced one
no he's always good for one at least
roger's out of the shotgun empty set
wait did they just what just happened
what do you mean
they threw the ball why do they go to
the 35
on a touchback that's a good question
maybe we have a little glitch there i'll
take it there's a glitch in the game
someone says
yeah and and it stop with me the
leaderboard's updated
rogers out of the shotgun second and
eight from the 37.
[Applause]
play action has time wagner get in there
get in there
it looks to run gets to the outside he
can fumble he can hit him slides for the
first down let's go
aaron rodgers picks up nine first and
ten at the 46.
i mean aaron rodgers sewing a little bit
of a wiggle there
he's got that uh he's got that at top
end speed
rodgers under center first and 10 from
the 46. hands it off to aaron jones gets
to the outside oh wagner get in there
is the crowd really was the crowd really
loud on that go pack go chan or what
yeah man it's lambo it's real football
not this you know what i mean
they have a marching band or is that
some music
nah man we need marching bands segments
that's vincent barty's ghost
from the 49. let's get it going baby
some snare drum
roger's under center from his own 49
play action
bullet pass completes it to devonta
adams he's kind of a sim god too
he has two he's had some moments he's
had some huge games and some kind of
quiet nothing games thought about
investing in his props he
i mean he had a he had a four touchdown
game and a three touchdown game that
we've called so but the rest of them i
think he did nothing
so mandarin tang saying you all need a
raise much love thank you
mandarin tang yeah you got no problem
watching this fake football game do you
all right where are you what do you get
angry
just because people said they they
wanted you to get angry like i'm
drinking over here you know
irish normally around the third beer and
first whiskey that
you get a little a little fire broken uh
jpg in the atc youtube saying madden
looks horrible
really he's one of those guys who will
get penetration well he has it
he's let his weight get out of control
completes underneath the lazar
gets jacked up by wagner but he hangs on
i took the lazard thing too so we need
this yes
lazard has two catches already two of
the three completions by aaron rodgers
he's a true sim guy
what is uh what was your what'd you get
the receptions prop out
five and a half that's easy money yeah
we need a we need a bobby wagner fumble
kramer gang
especially for this first quarter under
roger's under center split eye
hands it off gets the outside aaron
jones
backwards what are you doing didn't want
to get hit
i get it well that you know you know why
they drafted aj dillon now
it's that kind of soft play from aaron
jones
second and six at the 10. i mean both
errands were put into a locker by the
organization
this past draft rogers out of the
shotgun
second and six from the 10. hands it off
to jones or no that's jamal williams
first carry of the game
you see he reached the football forward
like we're seeing that we
definitely didn't see early on some new
animations
pete carroll pre-game was uh fighting on
stephen avey's behalf
conspiracy guys oh yeah well
what happened to building seven
[Applause]
all right let's go this is a big play
right now roger's under center third and
five
bobby wagner time back to throw there we
go down here
hell yeah well first quarter under is
cooked again
damn it i know sean we're uh we're a bit
of a cooler right now
i love when they show the meaningless
replay like don't slow mo the part
before he gets to the quarterback
maybe they'll try a fake like a bunch of
cowards
oh man that was so awesome phil goes up
and it's good
packers cut the deficit to four all
right 5
22 left to go in the first we got
ourselves a game here
and if you remember i mean in the nf in
the actual playoffs this was a pretty
good game
a back and forth affair seattle had a
shot
well i think now now it's time to deploy
i forgot how much it's annoying to watch
this seahawks team i think i was banking
on the fact that they've changed
so far metcalf has not been involved no
seattle just loves pounding the ball
that's why it's dangerous to get
involved in any of the
seattle passing props so what do we win
when
the packers lose here or nothing you
just push your bet with magic man
if the packers win i lose a bottle of
jameson but i win the bet against you so
i'm i've already hedged
oh wow it's a win-win situation at what
point are you guys what do you mean
you picked the team i had i had no what
was i supposed to turn down his bet
i had no idea all right
quick whistle there you guys should
raise the stakes and the losers should
have to take a ride down poot river
oh no in a boat not like swimming
i you know that's probably not the best
place to be hanging out nowadays
first and ten from there bird cobit
hangs around on for a while
out of the pistol wilson ready to go
from their own 25 hands it off to carson
to the outside
nothing there
and shout out to evolek 91.
what does everyone have for their bets i
agree it's a great question
seahawks let's let's groupthink this
let's get across the finish line
together this
power running game wilson under center i
formation second and ten from their own
25.
delayed handoff to carson breaks the
tackle
it's annoying that it worked a little
bit well i mean clock's our friend
kramer
picks up six third and four no i gotta
go there's four there's four minutes
left to go in the first and
colby's already looking for i like that
i like power football i don't like this
they're they're trying to
you know i love how they're on football
you know they're broken pete carroll's
noses
they're going after football and
christmas wilson out of the shotgun
third and four
rough seas he sees the blitz play action
gets rid of it completes it oh that's
olson olson
into packers territory at the 47 first
and ten
this guy was commenting or a commentator
in the xfl
he was in the off season
he now he's on a roster would you say
he's a bit of a renaissance man
uh sure yeah i'm on board with that
[Applause]
that's so russell wilson lock it goes up
and pulls it down
jesus christ wow i mean that's a pretty
good ball but just a great play by tyler
lockett
usually they drop those wow holy
seattle looking good
seattle about to go up 14-3 early here
and it might um yeah jesus i mean you
can't
sean how you feeling right now you're
all right horrible horrible
it's not just me getting loaded off
beers i just feel bad about this bet
packers are down 11.
self-control on the atc youtube saying i
want to see someone go to the hospital
wow now that's the football i like
that's some hard hits
bobby wagner could send someone to see
hawks minus
six and a half already first quarter
already
wow that's a huge swing in the line an
eight and a half nine point swing
you can of course get that over at my
booking daddy g promo code
tft if it goes past seven i
might start thinking about coming back
with the packers
well let's uh let's throw out some more
free playing cards down to six
but wagner hasn't forced a turnover yet
next touchdown or turnover 25
free play we already activated the bobby
wagner turnover free play
bonanza that one's not going to happen
no yeah
probably the next probably that
confidently too
calm a shot you want to do a unit on
what happens next
packers touchdown versus bobby wagner
forced turnover
yeah or bobby wagner turnover does it
have to be recovered by the defense
yeah okay
first and ten rogers under center from
his own 25.
[Applause]
back to throw man they are not
get has all day no one open
he's lucky that wasn't bobby white kj
right too he can make him fumble
picks up one on the scramble not much
there
both of these teams like do everything
they can on offense to not allow their
quarterback to be great
it's crazy 54 and a half is now the
total sean
juicing it up quick you're talking about
they got them aj dylan in the off season
and jordan loves it a little competition
rogers out of the shotgun in competition
full of pass to devante adams oh
he's lucky
wagner was there they just another guy
got there first
shout out to the brat stop in kenosha
wisconsin some of the best brats
in the greater north american area i'm
sure they got this game
at the broad stop up on the big screen
love us some bratz
rogers out of the pistol hands it off to
aaron jones
that was wagner on the tackle two slices
for
five getting lucky
self-control saying you guys playing no
the computer
is playing itself we're just
broadcasters
we don't want to uh you know we don't
want to ruin things by
tainting the game with our own play
split eye rogers under center second and
five from his own 44.
hits it up to aaron jones huge hole in
the outside play seems to be working
and a reminder the the line is already
up for the afc championship
tomorrow sometime around 5 p.m on the
west coast chiefs minus three and a half
on the road
in baltimore that play's working on that
side because bakari
well and the winner of this game is
going to take on the one-seed san
francisco 49ers who no one wants to bet
on so
this is a critical game because that's
the next game up
hands off to jamal williams and they're
doing a nice job establishing the run
here
certainly that that early interception
put them behind the eight ball but
they're getting a nice drive here going
and of course tomorrow kramer
around seven o'clock we will be doing
the sim bowl the super bowl championship
and we got super bowl squares you just
got to go to sportsgimlinpodcast.com
squares giving away 500 dollars
completely free
easy to sign up
wow first quarter under got dominated
three
i almost feel like taking the under 55
might be a wise play
felt both these teams really like like
they want to run they like running the
ball
feels like we kind of got out of the the
live numbers down to four and a half
shows
we had that crazy bomb by wilson and
that crazy turnover by rogers
seems like scoring is going to slow down
jamal williams with the carry breaks the
tackle
picks up a couple perfect spot for
wagner here
third and two they're gonna try the
packers gonna try to get cute with it
throw a little dink and dunk to the
tight end
wagner forces a fumble it does
it does seem like we're due yeah third
and two from the 39
oh they're just gonna run it and get
stuff high formation roger's under
center
hands it off to uh
and that's what they brought him here to
do picks up six first and ten at the 33.
dude i put one of his clips check out
the instagram for sports gambling
podcast
i mean he has a clip at lu against
louisville where he just
just destroys a defensive back i don't
know if i want to get involved in bed
actually betting me under there i feel
like i don't like that energy
rogers play action first and ten to the
end
considering his feet weren't set punches
almost pulled that down because this is
why i can't bet the under in this one
if guys are just going to be slinging 40
yard bombs rogers cut off his back foot
i mean he might have not landed in
bounds you don't want to call that a
drop but he certainly had a chance at
that
it would have been a hell of a catch
roger's under center second and 10 from
the 33.
hands it off to aaron jones there
my field goal is not the worst thing
here cut it to one score
reception metcalf has yet to touch the
ball
that's all right though it's only it's
early in the second quarter
yeah we just need all right we need a
wagner just blow up
third and 11. rogers heating up that red
x
from the 34 back to throw
checks it down underneath to jamal
williams not much there
settling for three again they're trading
touchdowns for field goals sean and
that's not
a successful strategy in the national
football league luckily they have an ace
of a kicker in mason crosby
from louisville
colorado 48-yard field goal from the
left hash
i saw a bar stool big cat tweeted out
hat of the day i saw the
colorado buffalo yeah it's up and it's
good
[Applause]
confusing to most how they use a bison
for a mascot but
that is fake news all right they had i
know
i personally know they imported one in
it's it's a bison though they have it's
not a buffalo don't you ever
make fun of ralphie right ralphie is a
bison
buddy 14 to six nobody in the u2 atc
youtube chat wants to know where the
white women at
you're probably not watching this if uh
the statistics are true i doubt anyone
any ladies are in here
and no i did not see the interview with
trump
what i'm going all in on trump uh
[Music]
i'm not getting political i'm just
saying i haven't seen it oh you're
getting political by addressing a
comment
what do you mean i'm not saying i didn't
watch it because of who was it but now
people can perceive things
welcome to life all right seattle will
take over on their own 25.
packers uh they've been moving the ball
got it got to do a little bit more as
far as converting
yeah got some getting some points and uh
uh
fernan over on twitch calling out the uh
my bookie website upgrade shout out to
them looking sharp
wilson under center first and 10.
and down he goes carson that's a big
minute it's
perry clark is a big man you don't want
to mess with that dude
i like the uh the old school packers
unis
atlas the sports gamer on our twitch
page saying
i just wanted to stop by and say what's
good props for keeping up the grind
trusting god and keep pushing good
things will happen all day baby
wilson with the scramble slides
oh just short i i don't i don't know if
god's involved in these madden
simulations but we'll see what
maybe he was maybe he was involved in
that fake field goal we are the sim gods
sean
uh oh he sees it wilson sees the blitz
third and one
from the 34. read option
and he's got it spin move breaks the
tackle
into packers territory well i didn't see
that i almost took
uh i almost took a lot of props i'll
stop saying that
but i almost took the russell wilson
over 60 and a half proud
cocoon it's getting funny there's some
funny comments going on in that chat
buddy
oh wow people are upset wilson out of
the shotgun first and ten midfield
first grab of the game right yep
i went i double dipped on him so we need
to get going
i followed you on the double dip oh
madden 420 saying tuning in from the
work truck
that that's a good way to win a free
play take a photo
make sure you're sending in your your
free play uh
your free play setups at gambling
podcast on twitter
wilson i formation hard count let's go
go go go go
the under is going to come in i should
have first down hands it off the car
yards rushing with carson deluxe picks
pointing out
matt wilson only has four i know throws
that's insane
how many yards not man i'm over there
well most of it
most of it's at like 40 yard bomb to
lock it
wilson under center first and 10 from
the 37 hard count
olsen in motion carson with huge hole at
the middle
this run game is solid they're they're
gashing
uh russell wilson has 95 yards four for
four
okay nine minutes left i feel all right
he's having himself a game here early
second and two
packers needed a stop turnover would be
great
from the 28 wilson with the heel kick
back throw
easy pitching catch beautiful
no oh they're saying incomplete oh what
a little bit of a brain fart didn't get
his feet in bounds can we get a replay
on that
great little review how do you not get
his feet in
hate this game they're not even gonna
challenge
wilson out of the shotgun from the 28
hands it off to penny and he gets the
first down
wow rashad penny your third down back
they love the shot the the five yards
deep
draw or handoff
yeah they should have challenged that
catch really could he use the the
metcalf
second catch wilson out of the shotgun
first and ten from the 26th back to
throw
feels the pressure gets rid of it hits
him into the sides
[Applause]
shoving it down their throats packers
we need a touchdown here colby i mean
touchdown
they're going to need a stop they're
going to need a turnover they're gonna
need a big play because they're just
they're just getting their pushed
in wilson empty set first and goal from
the five
looks to run and the ball damn it no
that's the turnover the packers needed
dude
he jinxed this 25 free play up for grabs
sending the send in the screenshot of
your setup
colby's getting angry at me yeah you're
good at jinxing things ryan
aaron jones we definitely need a
touchdown right here
second and six tweet us your setup at
gambling podcast
25 free play up for grabs
rogers out of the shotgun second and six
from his own eight
6 30 left to go awesome start for under
bettors
williams breaks free big play here picks
up a couple
third and two at their 12. bubble screen
perfect time for our bubble screen
to lazard loses five-year-old first down
it's a catch inspired minds it's not a
uh
email it's a twitter at gamblingpodcast
tweet us a photo
i formation rogers under center third
and two from the 12.
bubble screen to lazar oh no that's
devonte adams
gets the first down who's on the sticks
yeah that worked that never worked
[Applause]
getting parched
roger's under center trips up top first
and ten from the 15.
[Applause]
back to throne high throw but he gets it
to sternberg
[Applause]
quiet first half that's some uh
sternberger has some nice arm talent i'd
like to see him line up on her center
rodgers under center second and five
from his own 20.
[Applause]
back to throw checks it down to the
tight end
picks up a couple third and one a very
cha-cha
chow offense right here
[Applause]
still in the league playing under jim
mora
he's been working in the media for like
a decade they came out together
actually no i think he played under carl
derail how do the phillies lose to the
marlins every time it's insane
rogers under center hands it off to
aaron jones easily gets the first step
fumble come on this game is just melting
away all of a sudden
four minutes left to go in the first
half green bay three timeouts
should have listened to my own advice
and taken the under now that passing
number
is in question oh yeah we're
i mean we're not that bad actually
because they'll pass down the stretch
here he'll get
like he'll be at he'll be halfway home
rogers hands off
aaron jones who is that down he goes
for wagner is that the rookie from texas
tech
maybe who's 56.
jordan brooks that is the rookie from
texas tech second
and eight for the pack they're excited
about him
he was a guy they took too early right
they always take care
of it play action by rogers
plenty of time deep code
pretty deep i'll take you there's lazar
lazard with the grab
into seattle territory easy money like
aaron rodgers with that much time
that this game is not over they've
nailed this throwing motion it i think
that's the most impressive thing
and and right i mean if i'm
man i should have taken it when it was
six and a half i guess i want i i
greedily waited till
seven now it's it's much lower rogers
under center hands it off to aaron jones
jukes the outside almost a first down
picks up eight second and one two
minutes warning time i believe
yeah they'll run it down here let it go
to the two minute warning they have
three timeouts
best drive in the game but they need to
convert they need to get six
they've they've had some drives haven't
been able to get a touchdown
uh otto rich yes metcalf has a catch he
almost had two i don't know what
happened
colby am i watching the a's game not
currently
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
tft seahawks minus three and a half now
rogers completes it punches come on
first down and then some down to the 24.
oh timeout's being used
interesting your green bay
next play you're calling a timeout if
the pot doesn't stop right
i don't think you need a time sorry
seattle's got to start using them rogers
out of the shotgun first and ten
slides those up completes it underneath
the sternberger breaks the tackle
or close to another first down someone's
got to use a timeout come on
uh yeah i guess if you're seattle you
use one but bobby wagner let's go
where are you at son sternberger with
the second crab of the game
really quiet first half there foreign
yeah i mean he had a couple
early big hits no real separation rogers
first and ten
at the 14 out of the shotgun
checks it down he didn't get it he gets
out of bounds that's fine
no it was incomplete oh was it all right
even better
oh bobby wagner's getting ready to super
piss execute a drone strike
roger's out of the shotgun second and
ten from the 14.
[Applause]
back to throw plenty of time and we get
bubble
oh what
[Music]
i guess but god damn it he went
backwards up i know but he can't
like he can advance it because it's
under two minutes once he picks it up
it's that that's horseshit
third and 20 horrible play there by the
packers lineman that could have
been a
defensive touchdown right there now what
third and 20 from the 24. why'd they
call a timeout
dummies
rogers under center pack to throw has
time
completes it to devante adams it's oh
god damn it take it fourth and one
they're gonna kick it you i would go for
it here
i mean you gotta have some onions wow
they're not going to they're
and of course they are 22-yard field
goal from the left hash
[Applause]
it's up and it's good making it a
five-point game games i mean
huge swing for the packers they should
be down by way more
this guy looks like he's on meth what
what's up with those eyes
the kickers in this game are a bit a bit
loose they have so much swag
i uh you know it does feel like again
that lineman just
came in there beautifully picked it up
that should have been a touchdown going
the other way
if you're if you're a a packers fan
you're feeling pretty fortunate right
now and now
russ three time outs they have to
unleash him right they're not gonna just
run the ball
i hope i would hope so for our over also
well this is where he gets right back on
pace he's got 95
what was it 260 243
and a half
but why should the packers be ahead help
me understand that
what do you mean someone in the chat
saying the packers should be ahead
i mean they they've squandered three red
zone opportunities but
really seattle should be up by way more
yeah fumbled at the two yard line
fortunate shout out to shaggy colby with
that
with the sex appeal oh you know
apparently uh there's a bot in the chat
you know what an actual person could
find colby six wow
is that what you're implying no i mean
i'm not directly wilson looks to run
and he slides they use their timeout
throw the ball dude
pick up four yards another bomb
touchdown
yeah let's do it that would be it i mean
i feel like seattle and green bay have
played games like that
it was aaron rodgers hitting the hail
mary though
but i mean russ has completely of course
had nc er
at wisconsin against michigan state
remember that helmet
wild game but uh what rust did lose at
east carolina
wilson out of the shotgun sega then six
back to throw
takes the shot gets it off to penny come
on stays in bounds that's dancing
two timeouts they burned
and now this gets a little interesting
third and two packers have two timeouts
so if they don't get the first down here
they're gonna have to punt and maybe the
packers are able to sneak
sneak a little uh field goal action here
late oh what is this formation
i formation is this formation wilson
under center third and two
back to throw
[Applause]
they call the timeout at 20 seconds and
now we're gonna get some
last play the same thing happened last
game the half ended with some
time management
maybe we'll get a hail mary see i prefer
a hurry up there and then you have the
timeout to kill it and then you throw
the hail mary
[Music]
wow magic man wants to know if alex
smith's gonna start a game this year
that would be pretty
it's a great question i'm rooting for
him man i mean dwayne haskins sucks so
there's gonna be opportunity i hope not
because he's way better than dwayne
haskins and i'm an eagles fan
wilson overthrows it incomplete
look at metcalf wide open down second
and ten
take a shot ten uh there's some uh
booty eating talk going in the atc
youtube chat did you just call it booty
eating well that's what they're calling
it
and then uh tin somo saying eating booty
can give you pink eye ask fouchy
okay potter responding i guess i'll
learn the hard way
they run the ball first down carson
breaks it he could be gone
thirty twenty ten i was talking
about the play call too oh my god oh
what the just happened it's like
they run the ball
and then boom turns out carson's over
looking good you called his over out i
think he just went over
yeah god damn this packers team
oh man i've never seen that before they
were trying to run the clock out
that's why you don't kneel that's why
you hand it off can break a play like
that wow
oh look at this more kicker drip he's
just sprinting off the fields
oh sean this has gotten bad it's gone
from bad to worse i'm really curious to
see what what
number surfaces
packers now down 12 at home this is not
looking good
what do you think wilson has at halftime
110 115
something like that
what does he have passing yards wise
yeah yeah i'm sure the chat knows
they'll let us know or we can just look
ourselves in
eight seconds we're gonna have to really
sweat though i think that over
well they're gonna be up by so much i
think the problem is we're just not
like yeah seattle's gonna throw the ball
like 10 times in the second half
aaron rodgers though hail mary time yeah
if they can get a playoff
five seconds left to go they do have two
timeouts quick pass
and then timeout and then hail mary they
don't they don't have it
you don't think so no this packers team
sucks
wow you're in you're in the same camp as
aaron rodgers family huh you're the best
i'm the worst
seahawks minus oh they're kneeling wow
that's a real move
that is a move sean
got a little that eye shadow too might
be time to pounce on the second half
that'll do it for the first half 21-9
and the seahawks start with the ball oh
120 that's not bad
colby were right on pace oh my goodness
i mean they're just who was saying the
packer should be up by more
or by winning or winning the game or
what like what game are you watching
yeah five for five on third they're a
hundred percent on third down cramer
robert robert uh mariah sums it up best
with
uh you pete carroll pete carroll
sucks
okay i agree pete carroll denying
911.
i rush only eight attempts this is just
yeah who's he jimmy garoppolo this is
just a disaster for the packers
they're just getting pushed around
they've had three great drives they're
just settling for field goals
packers need to convert in the red zone
and they need to get a stop from the
seahawks what do you think that line
will be at
you know whenever it updates wow you had
to guess
i mean you got to make the packers
favored by a touchdown
i think i think you got to make the
packers favored by like six and a half
or seven
right do you yeah they'll come back well
knowing that wagner's gonna force a
fumble
factoring that in do you maybe
maybe so they open it the second half
line will be will be
six then right yeah iserson uh
i don't know man we gotta wait and see
this line or i'm sorry packers will be
favored by six right
five or six maybe maybe metcalf only one
for nine he should have two for about
17.
we do feel like we got robbed on that
one lazard looking good for us
on both what was the over on lazard the
the
the yardage it's like 60 something
wasn't it oh some
we're getting reports the second half
line is up
and it's it's minus six
so you know the sim creator himself
called it you're welcome
what do you think what do you think we
go we go should we
i don't need to get involved in that i'm
interested in the toe i mean i guess if
anything i would look to
play back against the seahawks here uh
with the packers because not to hedge
more than just to play the middle but
yeah so second half line packers minus
six now that
over 23 that's the part that's
interesting to me and now that i didn't
play the over and we're sitting right at
30 i'm feeling okay that i didn't play
the over
but or the under 23
sean what do you think over under that
feels like it over right
over if i had to i've been getting
burned on these you know what kramer
gang over 23
over 23 in the second half it's a little
bit of a hedge it's a little bit of a
hedge because it protects me if the
green bay starts coming back i'm staying
away we got a winner for the uh
25 free play shout out to ben
atletta adelita you got it
he said he's in depression after losing
three units on the chiefs well hopefully
this 25
free play helps you out you see this
shawn
zero punt so far yeah it's been a weird
game how's that possible
how have we not seen a goddamn punt
it's been a weird game right like green
bay has just eaten up a ton of the clock
but then seattle's just had two huge
plays that
bombed a locket that he pulled down that
chris carson run
i mean and then the turnover where
rogers just started the game off looking
like
a lot of regression indicators for
seattle i mean just looking at the
scoring summary
you see 47-yard pass
61-yard run i mean those are just
those are that five for five on third
down there's some areas of regression
opportunity
but we only have a half a football level
we're very fortunate kramer that
i mean wilson only has six completions
and he has 120 yards yeah and well again
when you have a 47-yard pass yeah yeah
oh man babyface shout out on twitch
looks like the packers moneyline's gonna
up a baseball parlay
that's why you don't cross streams bro
you don't change horses
i'm a one one sport pony
so i'm my second half back give me green
bay mine is six and a half it do we
pencil in seattle in the nfc
championship yet start having a man in
two world cup lines
do it game's over right jinx it jinx it
i dare you kramer i dare you to pencil
in
seattle and by the way is this green bay
packer team
yes you jinxed us with that fumble sean
real quick yes
somehow the redskins are favored over
the giants after this uh the team
i didn't give you the team total sean
seahawks 10 packers 13 and a half you're
telling me to see it
give me seattle over 10. wow that is low
that's ridiculous i'm i'm getting two
green bay minus six and a half that's
all you need
uh shout out to dick gerthsberger saying
mr danica has a passer rating of seventy
mr danica i like that what's happening
to their malibu beach house now that
they broke up
yeah what a weird cover story that was
packers down 12 at home i mean aaron
rodgers hasn't been the same since
jordan nelson left for oakland
gotta wonder maybe he made a maybe he
made a video he's a beach house
well now he's distracted by these guys
at the gym it's not the same you know
he's not settled he's out partying
he could have got his hand caught in the
pie what if jordy came down there still
hasn't learned how to chug a beer
well he went to well actually he went to
cal berkeley he probably just dropped
acid
ben flynn saying as soon as cramer says
seahawks over 10
the line dropped from minus 15 to minus
1 30. we're moving units
well i mean sim creators all right we
might know what's going on
creators sim gods we know we're talking
about we are on the sticks
what are we doing here is it time to go
oh it's always time to go skeletor are
we ready
or management or someone someone say
okay and i'll start this goddamn game up
broadstop says they're putting cheese on
the packers plus 225.
all right that's a good sign i heard
from the broad stock that means
packers are coming back go back go baby
and go brought go
colby dude do we hedge with plus 225
hell no we don't have i don't think we
head yeah we don't hedge
all right here and we're good go brought
go
i'm looking forward to doing that go bro
go bro go let's get it going kramer come
on
start this up please let's go baby
i don't need to say please do you need
my wife
well i'll just i'll just go i'll just
start it right here i'll just
maybe someone in the chat can say please
what's our guy's name at walgreens did
he ask you to say please
juan did you say the guy when i did
battle with over at the walgreens in
eagle rock
so at some point someone has to stand up
to sean in his ways
that's not his fault he doesn't know any
better all right someone said please
thank you garrett
big rich privilege saying don't say
please do your wife no i don't but
she asked me to say all right
happy wife happy life bro you know what
they say about trying to paddle up a
river
that didn't yeah it's a waste of goddamn
time
seahawks will take over at their own 30.
up 21-9 look for them to just get
conservative what are they gonna do just
pound the rock here to carson
unload let's go i got props to win
daddy's got kids to feed let's go
two tight end set wilson out of the
shotgun hands it off to carson
picks up three second and seven you know
i
the the running attack of seattle was
pretty impressive in the first half
i don't know can you remember seeing a
more impressive first i mean i know we
had one long run but they still
i think they ran for close to 160 yards
yeah
for consistency yeah cause you
jacksonville fournette had a good game
uh
[Applause]
[Music]
they just haven't done much in the
passing game but getting going here
second catch 34 yards first and ten from
their own 45.
and shout out to frank lagood who's in
in sole possession of first place right
now
in the football tournament wins contest
wilson high formation first and ten from
the
hands it off to carson doesn't do much
there and
hey maybe you missed the contest doesn't
matter you can still get involved in the
super bowl squares
all you're going to do is go to
sportsgamilypodcast.com
squares shout out to buffer t justice
and
i believe it's got to be the garrett in
the twitch chat because they're
they're tied for 19th place with 52
points
second to nine wilson out of the shotgun
from his own 46 back to throw
steps up in the pocket completes it to
greg olsen oh a nice tie
short of the first down good open field
tackle
come on third one got to run him over
there
it's all right i mean this is the one
team i kind of feel okay third and one
they've converted every one so
and they've done it with they've done it
running the ball mostly oh no he sees it
now you're in trouble
now you're in trouble wilson out of the
shotgun third and one
read option and down he goes the balls
loose
wow seahawks catch a break the lineman
picks it up forcing a fourth thing i
thought he saw it kramer
i thought you were pushing our best
players i think he's down
that's not a fumble it doesn't matter
they didn't
and now seattle forced the punt not a
good start for the over
first punt of the game oh hit him deep
potter's saying jesus people are betting
on this that said five
not only people are betting on it
they're winning money potter
and there's nothing sad about free money
but no going to the racetrack and just
betting on some random horses
well i mean i i would call out the fact
that had you tuned in on wednesday night
and had you tailed my picks yeah you
would have been up
22 units people are feeding their
families with this
22 units roger's under center first and
ten from the five
[Applause]
on the tackle jones picks up a couple
that's the type of guy does segment
seven
22 units is well i mean he's obviously
never have felt the weight of a unit in
his hand
you know he's felt a different kind of
unit he's more of a joystick guy
that's what you call it when you uh when
you're handling someone else's money
not me i handle my own money
roger's out of the pistol hands it off
to aaron jones there we go
picks up another couple third and five
funny anecdote we were on a little bike
ride i was on a bike ride with the kids
before uh before the games tonight
and we saw a car with a bunch of cowboy
stickers on it and the kids just
instinctually crossed the street to make
sure we were further away from it
they knew there might be some form of
disgusting action beautiful parenting
right there
yeah rogers third and five from the 10.
oh my god people wide open i honked at
the uh yeah
i'll jump together i love when they do
that i was driving around i saw
a dude uh in a cowboy's jersey walking
along the street and i honked at him
and like kind of gave him like this and
you know in hindsight i wasn't wearing
any eagles gear and it was a it was a
black dude so maybe just thinks i'm
horribly racist
i was ready to like drive back and roll
down the window
hey i think black lives matter i just
want you to know it's all about the
cowboys
and that's it wasn't any i don't see
color and i apologize i know you guys
going through my dress i'm terribly
sorry can i buy you a slurpee
listen yeah i know i mean it's important
the other day we were driving and
the same thing we saw a cowboys fan and
the the girls are in the back like fake
waving for a second
and they go to wave back and then
they're just like
i mean it you have to train him early or
something horrible could happen
of course it could be next thing you
know you're hanging out in jerry jones's
hotel room or whatever wilson back to
throw out of the shotgun first and 10.
come on man who is that that was was
that olson
what are we doing here like this is
almost like they're trying to operate
they're trying to operate between the uh
between the 40s right now so we can't
get any points
dissley would have been a fun uh player
probably no that was olson right no that
was 89 dislike
olson's 88. wilson out of the pistol
second and 10 midfield
hand it off again to carson gets to the
outside
jesus he's having a game down to the 42
on 10 carries i mean what's penny got
he's not he's not too shabby either
yeah they're just running it down their
throats don't overthink it we don't need
to do a shotgun option reed just the old
fullback dive
right here never fails no they're gonna
yeah jesus
they keep running the redox disgusting
maybe a pass turn one from the 42 out of
the shotgun
is that a spy or is that a blitz olsen
in motion
that's wilson looks to it should have
worked but he didn't
accelerate he's jogging he's thinking
about his child winning
fake it out oh now now we're gonna get
that long field goal miss colby
59-yard field goal i hate that play
called they're gonna go for it
i think they're gonna go for it they
totally wouldn't do it in real life but
i think they're
jesus 59-yard field goal packers are a
nickel
playing for the fake here oh he got it
i think he might oh that's
good yeah jesus christ wow
mr thick dick huh yeah that's a unit
right there
are you kidding me green bay's offense
sucks
we're kramer
what are we doing for the uh what's the
live line over at my bookie daddy
i'll let you know as soon as it pops up
sean
looks like the money lines trickling in
plus 400
for the packers sean plus 400 for the
packers
they're down what 15. you know it's been
seven minutes and it's only been a field
goal and you're telling me 225
to 400 that seems like good value if you
still like the packers why not
i'm not gonna do that but 49 is the
total nine and a half now the spread
you've been on the wrong side of history
tonight sean i know i'm going cold man
this is great trying to live off that
lazard prop colby i told you i wasn't
gonna pay him i was never gonna pay sean
ryan cars is saying are they just color
commentating on computers playing each
other
we're not just doing that we're also
providing betting lines and then he
follows it up with this is what i needed
oh yeah you're welcome yeah uh a shout
out to america america america
over on twitch hey best commentators on
the planet i seek knowledge
on if you all think rogers will hit over
one and a half passing touchdowns
i think the game flow is going to be
helping you come uh come fourth quarter
yeah aaron jones the carry they're they
gotta get more aggressive
god damn it they're they're still
conservative they're waiting
to say kj wright's having a better game
than bobby wagner thus far
yeah i mean wagner hasn't had again
early a couple big hit sticks early but
not much after that
a team total over 21 and a half cashed
for the seahawks cacao
rogers out of the shotgun second 12 from
the 23. another handoff
jesus christ it's not going to work sean
throw the ball people out this packers
seem so frustrated
yeah seriously
uh people asking about that field goal
earlier 59 yards 59 yards
hey not mad matt marshall says when do
y'all
do podcasts uh we do about three of them
a week
and uh yeah sports game on podcasts
whatever
wherever you find podcasts incomplete to
devonta adams another three and a half
for this packers team and they're just
they're just looking like dog and
check out the college experience i'm in
the midst of doing 130
over uh over summertime here
yeah what colby's trying to say is he's
previewing
all 130 division one teams like an
absolute maniac
fbs i guess and now we got the one
let's go baby oh special teams are
defensive touchdown
plus 600. well that was first touchdown
i think i don't was that any time
or win a chicken dinner all right free
play let's get one out
tony punter not even trying oh my god he
got steamrolled
this is not a good look sean good for
the
seahawks over 10 second half they just
they're they're sitting on it now
it's a push kramer do we what if we do a
trivia question here for the uh for the
free play a little trivia let's scott
bowser just texted me a trivia question
was it a good one it is all right i
won't i won't answer it i'm sure i
already know
minus 10 in a row but great i don't know
if you know this promo code tft over at
mybookie.eg seahawks now minus 10 and a
half
plus 500 is the line 50 is the total
lebron stuff who is the first
national league dh to hit a home run
it happened today oh okay it's a topical
one
it is and uh we're witnessing history
here as we're doing these madden sims
and i threw it out into the chat so
first one
it is a historic home run getting a lot
of suspenders
yeah the twitch chat all over that
right they nailed it i i'll give it to
uh
ice iverson cespedes
was the first national league dh to hit
a home run
send us cespedes
yeah yeah what are you laughing at
coleman for this okay
you have it you have to tweet us at
gambling podcasts with your account
number we'll get you paid
do your thing sean you got this
shooter shoot bro i'm sorry 15 and a
half and
ten to one is now the total holy
and then dante adams catches it and now
picks up 13.
if you're sitting on an aaron rodgers
prop now you this is when he's got
now they have no choice but to activate
well we need that lazard prop too
and candidly i think i might
take packers plus 15 and a half
what are we sitting on right now you got
to get a touchdown one of these times
right
first and ten six forty seven left to go
in the third round what are they doing
still running this uh this playthrough
matt lafleur can just go himself
i'm tired of this he sucks
what are you doing sucks this is
what you call cookie
cookie oh i can't talk up
cha-cha-cha
yeah colby at least i can say my own
10-1 though is that guy over here
talking he can't even say his own
catchphrase
second and six rogers out of the shotgun
ten to one jamal williams oh beard just
almost came out my nose
green bay's ten to one yeah there's
actually some value there
all right ice iverson is saying we can
give it to someone else
because he doesn't have twitter i like
that making a stance you jack
all right send in a tweet of your setup
at gambling podcast the second winner
i'm looking at it right now was deluxe
picks
all right aj dillon breaking through
tackle with the grab
if you wanted to throw it at a friend of
the program who was also second in line
if that's okay with you sean sure is
ryan uh-oh
[Applause]
why'd you why'd you have to go after
now he's grumpy it's fun
i am grumpy now he's going to be losing
money over here i need some brats i'm
losing money the packers are garbage
i'm rooting for the packers even though
i find them annoying what's funny is
while you were gone i
i brought that up i said i i wondered
how soon before
this gambling this unit gambling got
real now that you're on the wrong side
of it
mercedes loses looks great right on
point colby
he's already pissed off five units was
that limit
five units is my limit shot you're gonna
rogers empty set
second in inches out of the shotgun from
the 40.
back to throw has time almost throws an
interception to bobby west
the hitman himself
wow this is almost like too easy sean
i'm i'm not is it time to pencil them in
and just have them whip
up the spread yeah by the way reminder
the symbol will be played on a neutral
field
oh there's rogers gets pushed back
[Applause]
where should the uh symbol be played
beautiful hawaii for the pro bowl
no wherever they're wherever they're
gonna play the actual super bowl i think
that's oh
filthy is it going to be a dome what is
it
fourth in inches from the 40. who's out
there in the world that knows this and
they're punting
oh my god you cowards fake
you soulless cowards
why would you punt you're down 22. 18.
a pretty good punt there sean they got
uh they netted 22 yards got inside the
20.
oh man sean it might be you you might
just want to
you want to just reset the game start
over i'm gonna reset it
anyone cool with us resetting the game
no get the out of here i'm loaded
right now i need
i need uh another point from the
seahawks to hit the
second half over it's gonna take place
at raymond james stadium
russell wilson looking to run oh that's
perfect the pirate ship
yeah oh that's beautiful
that's great for strip clubs so
excited it is one of the strip club
capitals of the country
matt leflore really a douchebag i mean
imagine
being so into yourself that you're
willing to waste the last couple years
of aaron rodgers
you drafted jordan love what a jackass
move wilson out of the shotgun second
and five bubble screen
but isn't that what they said about when
they drafted aaron rodgers from the head
breath five
no no until i mean
brett favre was holding on a little bit
longer if you know what i mean he was
way older and
aaron rodgers was supposed to be like a
you know top ten
pick first overall and fell all the way
into their lap yeah they weren't
he wasn't like this random darling draft
guy you know
third and seven wilson out of the
shotgun from his own 21.
back to thrill has time intercepted put
it in the end zone
let's go baby thank you russell wilson
we're alive whoa oh and he's
he's got his dick out oh my god so at
least we have one packers touchdown
wow the defense outscoring the offense
well not technically on this uh
once again our third quarter under sean
played yeah
they're going for two to make it a 14
point game rogers under center back to
throw
certain burgers open up top he's got
he's got the guy he looks to run
and slides into the end zone he started
the slide before he scored
you tried that all last year he just
discount double check yeah
jesus rogers with the swag and now it's
it it's a 14-point game
don't look now sean the uh here come the
packers hopefully you got some of that
10-1 action sean the power glove is so
bad asks how do i place a wager
all you got to do is go to mybookie.hg
deposit with the promo code tft
you get 100 deposit bonus and then
once you're good to go you just check
out the madden sims area on the side
very easy to use and you get involved in
live action where the total
sits at 54. the money line is about to
come out and i'm
i'm guessing it's still going to be in
the all right plus 750 is the money line
i'll let you know what the spread is
when it drops
imagine imagine getting a pick six
touchdown and
and it's still plus 750 on the money
line jesus christ
i mean and for those asking um
yes you can bid on the nba scrimmage
games and if you sign up
uh this week 10 world series future bet
completely free so a lot of options
seahawks minus 10 and a half now i
should have grabbed that 15 and a half i
knew it
that's a scary like that was the worst
possible thing that he could have done
though
yeah it also gives us a better chance
that metcalf gets more involved now now
they gotta
they gotta move the ball they gotta
score one more time now wilson
under center back to throw first and ten
takes it down to olson turns up field
gets a first down
what was wilson right now 154 damn come
on now
i know that's what i'm saying like oh oh
hello
moving and shaking that he learned that
move back when in college at the
university of miami in the seventh floor
floor gang notable rap group if you're
not familiar i highly recommend
looking that up on youtube seventh floor
gang greg olson
another first down carson blown back
he's gonna lose yards is that a play on
like the seventh tower
like uh it was pre nine eleven
okay second and twelve i like where your
head's at
i don't think it was three nine eleven
like in the illuminati rap group
you know wasn't it but it was a bunch of
dudes football players in miami i'm sure
they weren't that thoughtful in the name
they probably just lived on the seventh
floor
i'm gonna guess they probably just lived
on the seventh floor wilson back to
throw
that is metcalf metcalf catches it keeps
his feet in bounds falls down to the
ground
i need a little bit more yardage than
that i'll still take the receptions
if we push on the um all right if the
magic man good question if the three of
us had a bottle of jameson and all three
started taking shots who would drop
last i'm pretty sure we could finish a
bottle of jamo yeah
wilson back to throw gets it to the
outside hits him in stride
who's 18. that is
who is swain oh he threw through a punch
you said
i like it chippy here i like that i just
fired a punch in that guy's chest
make football great again i like that
first and ten i formation from the 42.
say straight up punch that dude you see
mike tyson's coming back
love it roy jones i'm a little concerned
about roy jones like he
he does not i know he does media and
but he he looks like the brains
coming close to
the end and i believe tyson can still
hit mike what happened
i broke my back what do you mean my back
is broken
what part
[Laughter]
[Applause]
it's encouraging dangerous throw i mean
mike tyson's gonna him up
i know they're not trying to knock each
other out but doesn't mike tyson
accidentally knock out roy jones i got
the heart of lions tigers and bears
i think i like the schwarzenegger one
better honestly but that's pretty good
wilson under center second and ten from
the 42.
hands it off to carson nothing there
uh we got to get at least five yards for
a field goal here this dude nailed like
a 57 yarder before
and make sure you hit that like button
make sure you hit that subscribe button
that like button
head over to twitch.tv slash sports
gambling podcast
follow us colby's going to be playing
some techno bowl spinal
yeah wilson out of the shotgun
down
[Applause]
come on this they don't want to
score points
they're they're allergic right now we're
in trouble cool we're
i'm legit not relaxed anymore
seattle had to punt and things are
getting interesting this
even when these games it looks like a
blowout these madden sims
madden knows what the kind of a
10-yard punt
12-yard punt packers will take over at
their own 30.
the ghost of lombardy
can they make it a one score game can
they get back in this thing
rogers out of the shotgun first and ten
from his own 30.
what the we're this is bad oh
come on sternberger couldn't hold on
well now this involves the packers
offense which is just
done jack sure they didn't
even score the touchdown
i guess we don't have to be that worried
colby that's the problem
and i'm nine and a half is the live
number
the money line's down to six to one now
58 and a half is the total
uh i think the did the second half total
come in roger's out of the shotgun
completes it to davonte adams hey
why did he stop throwing it to lazar oh
no yeah what happened to lazar
we're going to lose all my bets what's
going on
how many points do we have in the second
what eight points and
10 points so 18. what are you talking
about everybody second half points how
many points do we have
oh okay i think i think 18.
roger's out of the shotgun first and 10
from the 48.
come on where's the bobby wagner big
play picks up two
to williams whole reason i picked the
god damn seahawks
the second half over has to be a little
relaxed there's no way they're not
getting over
23 right shawn brought up saying their
cheese is getting shredded don't worry
bro
stop rogers to the rescue they're in
seattle territory second and eight
pull it past davonte adams again
dominating right now
how many catches does he have
look at that arm challenge
adam's i feel like a quiet six for 110.
he's kind of just getting going but
the packers have had these drives their
problem have been converting in the red
zone
huge opportunity for rogers in the
packers empty set
five receivers out
[Applause]
back to throw surveys the field default
of the end zone
[Applause]
at the one and he's got his feet in
and this is the aaron rodgers we know
brown with the catch
deep pull there is that an island in
bermuda
st thomas that's where uh that's epstein
island
that's a different place roger's under
center first and goal from the one
wagoner time there we go aaron jones
breaks attack oh
wow bobby wagner able to take him down
zero yard pickup almost almost got
rejected probably almost fumbled and
then
almost got the touchdown he almost broke
a bobby wagner attack
he broke like three people's tackles i
feel like
second and goal now at the one heavy set
i formation let's go bobby wagons gonna
hand it off to jones again maybe
oh they do play action kj right
no look we don't need bobby wagner we
got kj right
what a horrible play call you can't be
wrong if you're right kramer
oh i like that look at just how much
open space up top
colby colby nailed that one so right
roger's out of the shotgun third and
goal from the 10. you need to put it in
do not if you miss this you can't kick a
field goal
throw it to the endzone to the end zone
get there guys come on do it
out of bounds beautiful
why are you trying to be down they're
going to go for it they're going to kick
a field goal
100 they go for it
[Music]
and here comes the field goal have you
been watching these sims ryan
they're cowards and the the packers
their fourth field goal of the game to
cut it to 11.
maybe this will end up being the
difference though who knows
99 they were gonna go for it that one
percent stuck in there on me what are
you talking about
so do i i don't think i i'm glad i held
off on sending the
seattle san francisco that's a hell of a
match-up for the nfc championship that's
to me that's a more intriguing match-up
you know what it is oh bring him on come
on let's end this game
let's go let's go to the funeral always
better on black let's go to rogers
funeral
wesley snipes cramer you're
getting free uh
whoa oh what's that there we go magic
melon weed
okay let's do this hell yeah brian ross
i like watermelon or like melon like
honeydew
whoa i mean it's probably good
you know yeah i trust all things magic
melon how could it not be good yeah
anytime
any type of weed from northern
california or oregon oh uh
he's he's sending us a tweet it's 40
indica 60 sativa
i'll take samples so potent and intense
may be sedating
hopefully it comes before the camping
trip
[Laughter]
all right wilson takes over up 11 at
their own 25 9 51 left to go the winner
will move on to the nfc championship
carson he's tough to take down
very conservative play calling but hey
after the way wilson's almost he threw
one pick six almost through another
i mean at this point did we just say
it on our on our over
passing yards a lot of my props are in
trouble right what does he have like
once
has he thrown a passing touchdown no
right yeah he has to lock it a 60 yard
oh that's right so i need one wilson out
of the pistol
hands it to carson again picks up a
handful
and third and short he's over 100 sean
[Applause]
yeah i mean wilson throws a long
touchdown to metcalf that would be
just icing on the cake
and then when green bay comes back i
need a lot of stern burger over the
middle
third and four from their own thirty is
it colby he sees it
wilson back to throw there we go
could use a little bit more yards but
all right but look if we push and get
the receptions
on and and mister we still need two
catches though
it can happen one downfield hopefully
that that incompletion is going to haunt
us cleats
that happen in the first half yeah
you're right that was
what 20 yards yeah 15 something like
that
wilson under center 8 13 left to go
running the clock out here
why are they you should be loading the
box that's all they do is run the ball
they're just this this is the most
frustrating game they got a big play
with the pick
six they had a great drive and they're
just
dog they're going to see they've
been the better team by a mile
no they have but it's been frustrating
because green bay has had chances to be
in this game and they just want nothing
to do with it yeah
wilson again hand it off to carson jesus
you're getting nine yards of carry here
what are you doing that's a legit like
that's a this would be an interesting
matchup though
seahawks 49ers nfc west rivalry
kind of a similar game style are we are
we calling it should i send it in
sure send it in sherman against his
former team
i need colby to be okay with me sending
it in no there's no way they
turn it over here
get rid of it takes the pressure
now 199. okay we could do this we're not
good no we're pretty dead
you're dead we're pretty dead they're
not they're gonna throw like maybe one
more pass in this game
i mean it could be a 21-yard touchdown
right now and then then we're close
[Applause]
come on throw it right here wilson out
of the shotgun
yeah first and ten yes completes it yes
oh my god what
like why are they pat i'm good we're 32
yards away man
personal from the nine we're gonna need
another possession though
we're gonna get another possession six
minutes do you think so
both teams have three timeouts got to
get it i mean if they if the package
have any chance you're gonna need the
turnover or a quick stop to force a
field goal maybe you have hope
i didn't hit send yet but i've queued up
the uh the matchup
wilson hands it off to carson up the
middle not much there don't run it
throwing is your best option here
wow i'm pretty sure i assigned a lot of
points to seattle
second and goal from the seven
yeah i mean seattle definitely would be
a team to play in this type of thing
especially if you're looking at that and
zig i mean they're the only
formation throw it damn it throws it out
of the end zone that stops dude
a touchdown here right there put a
touchdown here we cash that
touchdown prop golden that's what i'm
saying look dude he was wide open right
there he panicked i can
win wilson i you know the name
wilson's kind of growing up i'll be
honest all i'll do is win it
third and goal from the seven closer out
of the shotgun throwing again
no
[Applause]
[Music]
written all over it well guess what
ladies and gentlemen we
we will be so now what do we have we
have a left
this will send us over for the second
half this will send us over for
seattle's team
total in the second half opportunity to
catch a couple bets right here sean
can we get it done let's get a block
here fourth and goal from the seven
don't fake it 24 yard field goal what's
up
man that's good am i circling bets boom
give me a cash register have some have
some respect sean just because you're in
a bad mood
this this green bay team is just so
annoying i mean
listen if you're if you're in the twitch
chat especially like
let people know what it's like to follow
the kramer gang
you build a room full of gold that's
what happens you follow the kramer gang
you play you win you get paid over on
mybookie.ag you use that promo code tft
and then you build a room where you put
all the gold
or bitcoin or soy i have a bitcoin room
it's a good room to have yeah but the
soy and the bitcoin can cohabitate in
the same room
bitcoin doesn't take up a ton of space
love the bitcoin big fan of the bitcoin
seattle up 34-20
cramer 100 milligrams uh next weekend
stay tuned i don't know i'm scared but i
want to do it i want to i want to push
my limits i'm thinking about joining a
pyramid scheme
all right well you got this really hot
girl that wants me to like hang out
but i think the catch is that she wants
me to like
buy some of that no no no colby
cutco knives
colby listen bro no
i mean i got the columbia at home but i
could double zipper oh no it's not it's
not a scam called me it's multi-level
marketing
i mean here's my advice do you want to
be a business owner or if you wanna
don't embarrass yourself bring your
checkbook uh if i hit you up in like a
couple weeks
will you buy some of my product roger's
out of the shotgun first and ten from
his 24 throw it deep
throw it deep at least throw it
interesting all right he's scrambling
i'll take that he's gone
40 45 takes a shot
interesting okay get up throw the ball
like really forrest gump right
there in like two weeks if i call you
and will you know i'm not gonna i'm not
sure i'm not gonna enable this behavior
i will not enable this behavior
dude just deal with a prostitute at
least then you understand what you're
buying
the oldest profession person ten rogers
plenty of time again it throws it away i
mean it's an honorable industry
but i'm intrigued by this whole pyramid
thing no you're not
what is the pyramid that's called
marriage bro you can choose to pay a
chick for one night or you can get
married and be
for the rest of your life right i
think that's how it goes
oh what is the pyramid i i need to find
out
supposed to go on a hike
[Applause]
roger's back to throw second and ten
completes it to
oh oh i was gonna show you no lose no
way he held on to that guy
how is he not out of the game he i mean
he look he might be concussed you see
he's
not gonna hit that either dude are they
gonna show this replay
because that might have been a helmet to
helmet sean
i know you're big on the rules oh yeah
get him out of here
rogers out of the shotgun third and ten
can they get a first down
oh another drop god this team sucks well
now they know they have to go for it
yeah now now when it doesn't matter they
will go for it i
i i'm telling you i'm just waiting for
the hammer to drop here
why why why a hammer when knives are
perfect i'll buy
you you want to buy something wagner's
heating up looks like he's coming on the
plants
roger's out of the shotgun fourth and
ten from their 45.
oh faked him fake back to throw oh
devonta
and he drops it of course this game is
stupid
you catch the ball adams
oh man sean's angry see why not what do
you want me to be happy
like people like why are you upset
because your team's losing uh because my
team's losing what do you want to
throw a party solstice out of the
shotgun first and ten at the 45.
what's the party i got a timeshare for
you
someone just called me a giant
juvenile grandpa
i've had three 500 milligram gummies
since this game
started a hundred years first of all i
don't believe that
that's like when someone tells you that
they they take shots of everclear right
tweet us the rappers
i mean i i'm thoroughly impressed if
you've eaten 1500 milligrams
of thc that's like joey diaz level
i mean you must be a large individual
are you a 400 pound band
it's certainly possible i mean i i have
a pretty high ti i would say i have a
pretty high tolerance like the average
human being takes like five milligrams
and they're good
no you wouldn't you gave me like a
tic tac in vegas it was five
weeks he was destroyed
peer pressure he's like this one's not
bad kobe wilson out of the shotgun third
and eleven from the 46.
oh yeah those pills are crazy run run
run run run run
gets the first down you guys you gave me
that and then we went to like a
five star dinner i got some waitress
asking me about an old fashioned
i can't answer this question
right now i got bigger things going on
in my brain my bad
i'm sorry how do you like your your
steak cook sir god damn it just make
sure you should know
make sure on the human resources forum
to update your update your status
well you need a contact uh for colby
emergency contact
just said colombian chick wilson under
center first and ten high formation hand
it off to
come on take a shot deep are they gonna
first timer two minute warning dude
they're not gonna throw it again
we need 31 yards kramer just one shot
deep right now
we're at the 36. we're at the 36 we
could do it right now
yeah just metcalf for a touchdown like
just say it
send him deep he's on the bottom of the
screen no he's on the top of the screen
play action wilson under center i
formation
[Applause]
play action carson down he's getting the
pass
it's got to be a pass third down
yeah yeah always pick the opposite of
sean shout out to t
mckee that's an accurate statement i'm
on
i am cold right now i'm going to get it
hot close it out strong
tomorrow night 3 p.m
seattle 49ers nfc championship
5 p.m we got a great one chiefs ravens
and then the symbol 7 p.m pacific
make sure you get the symbol square
sports gamingpodcast.com
all right i sent it over seattle
san francisco opening game of the
championship
saturday a triple header why kick the
field goal right now when you could take
just one shot
throw the ball because it's fourth and
eleven they're up
you know what's going to happen right i
don't care about it i just click send
we're gonna see a blocked field goal
return for a touchdown
and they still won't win i just sent
over the match-up
oh 51-yards where is that earlier in the
game a guy hits a 59-yarder the other
way going the other way
no it was the same one no it's going the
other way i'm almost positive it's going
that way going the other way
all right what what now now the game's
not over
yeah it is no it's not all right
the game's never over with live wagering
do we have a live line kramer
oh that's true we should you should be
paying attention to that roger's back to
throw first and ten
interception completes get out of here
he's got he's got a five he's right on
it
four he needs to catch it 58 and a half
is the total
ten to one is the money line seahawks
minus ten and a half which side do you
take
wait i'm gonna take green bay plus ten
and a half they get a touchdown here
okay roger's added to the shotgun i
think i would too actually
even money on that they got to get one
offensive touchdown
lizard lazar sternberger oh foreign
that's 20 seconds not going off the
clock
it's a huge play free time out they only
have one left sean that
you'd be down to a minute 10 right now
if not for that
they're gonna need an on-site kick
that's the thing if they had three
timeouts you could still
score and hypothetically kick it away if
they can score before a minute they have
a chance because they won't know to
kneel it
rogers out of the shotgun first and ten
from the thirteen level screen lazard
back to throw
[Applause]
now it's over second and three
yeah oh for three all three red zone
trips three field goals that's the story
of the game
no four four that's okay yeah if
they have four fields roger's back to
throw
has plenty of time spin moves what are
you doing get out of bounds god damn it
oh no this team is just
gonna call a timeout at one minute
according to that guy from the last game
lie not letting the clock bleed
no urgency here on this dumb ass packers
team oh man i think the seahawks are
gonna have to wear these gray uniforms
again third down right now you throw to
lazar wilson out of the shotgun
to the end zone is that lazard two no
it's adams
almost had a touchdown their first of
the game well field goal right
yeah play it safe get the field goal
kramer who are you gonna pick
nfc championship game you're riding your
seahawks i gotta see
we haven't seen the line but i gotta
imagine i'll be on the seahawks
this seahawks team yes rogers out of the
pistol fourth and six from the nine do
they run it here they didn't need
russell wilson and they won this game by
two touchdowns
plenty of time oh he's out of bounds how
do you catch that and not
get a touchdown that's our two catches
from the first down though all right two
catches for lazard still alive
there you go colby that was adams no i
know what he's saying they have more
players yeah
the bubble screen right here than they
run a lot of scrimmage
find him in the end zone right now
roger's out of the shotgun first and
goal from the three they're gonna hand
it off do it
do it he's right down here he's right
right across the middle he's he's oh my
god still alive baby
there were so many people open i
couldn't find any of them dude lazard
was open for a touchdown but i don't
want that
run him on a shorter route please
second and goal from the three oh they
tweeted
the guy with the 500 milligrams tweeted
out so
is the dude legit i don't know i'm
i'm not roger's out of the shotgun
second and goal from the three
hold day again jesus christ
what the is going on i don't see
any notifications that gambling podcast
perfect time for a bubble screen
maybe he tweeted at me
third and goal from the three can they
get a touchdown
[Applause]
oh no they hand it off
yeah bobby wagner almost forced his
first
so bubble screaming oh there you go i
got it
in a face mask
oh wow i'm gonna get i'm gonna this
package is great sean i just retweeted
it what is that
can you go back to that package hold on
i'm gonna retweet it from the camera
grateful dead album cover
i'm guessing that means total in the bag
is 500 milligrams just
roger's back to throw a fourth and goal
from the two
is that loss yes that's lazar but that's
going to be an incomplete
[Applause]
wait we still got another try then no
yeah no you do
no it's over oh wait oh yeah because
it's great as an incomplete pass
you losers damn it god they're
so bad
safety safety safety doesn't do anything
let me get the ball back and i get my
two completions now you're right
wilson i formation under center get
there
hand it off to him carson breaks
defense is trash
that's it that's the end of the game all
right
the package is pretty dope i'll give you
that bro
that's great dude that's fantastic all
right
all right that'll do it wow what what a
couple could get i mean
this game wasn't good but it was still
entertaining there at the end
got the nfc championship tomorrow night
3 p.m
tomorrow afternoon what a tribute to his
newly born daughter with a win
pacific seahawks 49ers then
five o'clock pacific ravens
chiefs and then seven o'clock pacific
the symbol
the first ever symbol presented by
mybookie.ed promo code tft
all things comedy or the sports gaming
podcast give us a follow on twitter
gamblingpodcast hashtag tft
subscribe to the podcast leaderboards
update will be coming soon
thank you for participating in the
sports gaming podcast
for the sports gaming podcast i'm sean
sack of the money green and he is ryan
sorry real quick sean just updating my
balance is that plus
five units on you now you are plus five
that's all crammer let it
ride
[Music]
so
you